WERE COMMENCING THE HEARING OF
THE LAST CASUAL HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY.
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE -- AND WE
ARE ABOUT TO HAVE A QUORUM.
SO THE FIRST THING I'M GOING TO
DO IS ASK THE SECRETARY TO CALL
THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH QUORUM
[inaudible]
QUIRK.
WORK IS HERE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ IS HERE OBERNOLTE.
WELCOME HERE [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS IS HERE MURATSUCHI.
WHAT CITIES HERE SO WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE FIVE MEMBERS OKAY
VERY?
FIRST THING I WANT TO ANNOUNCES
THAT WE ARE PULLING.
OUR COMMITTEE IS PULLING SB
EIGHTY SIX DORADO -- WE WOULD
THEN HAVE NINE BILLS LEFT THREE
OF WHICH ARE ON CONSENT.
HOWEVER I'VE BEEN ASKED TO TAKE
A WE'LL GET TO THE REST OF THE
AGENDA IN A MINUTE.
I'M GOING TO FIRST ASK OUR
CENTER MINING TO TALK ABOUT HIS
BILL I SB.
TWO HUNDRED WELL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT.
A TODAY WHAT IS THE RESULT OF A
NEGOTIATED AGREEMENT AMONG
LEADERSHIP OF BOTH HOUSES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AS MANY OF YOU ARE WELL AWARE
THEIR FAMILIES AND OVER THREE
HUNDRED COMMUNITIES ACROSS OUR
STATE WHO CANNOT DRINK.
BAYS OR COOK WITH THE WATER THAT
COMES OUT OF THEIR TAPS.
ARSENIC LEAD URANIUM NITRATES
CHROMIUM SIX IN T. C. P. ONE TWO
THREE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
DEADLY CONTAMINANTS FOUND IN
DRINKING WATER.
THESE COMMUNITIES AND THEY'RE
OFTEN LOW INCOME RESIDENTS HAVE
LONG CALLED FOR THE CREATION OF
A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCE. TO
ADDRESS THE LONGSTANDING GAPS IN
FUNDING NEEDED TO PROVIDE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
AFTER THREE YEARS OF RELENTLESS
ADVOCACY COUNTLESS PRESS
CONFERENCES COMMUNITY TOURS AND
BUS TRIPS TO THE CAPITAL THE
VOICES OF THESE FAMILIES HAVE
FINALLY BEEN HEARD.
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED
REPRESENTS A COMPROMISE PLAN TO
PROVIDE A LONG TERM. FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
I PLUGGED THE GOVERNOR IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF BOTH HOUSES FOR
CRAFTING THIS SOLUTION AND
HAVING THE COURAGE TO ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS IN AN IMMEDIATE
IMPACT FULL MANNER.
SPECIFICALLY SB TWO HUNDRED WILL
ESTABLISH THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF THE STATE
WATER BOARD.
IN WILL TRANSCRIPT A HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND UNTIL THE YEAR
TWENTY THIRTY TO PAY FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER SOLUTIONS IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THE MEASURE REQUIRES THE WATER
BOARD TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO DEVELOP
AN ANNUAL EXPENDITURE PLAN ON
HOW TO BEST ADMINISTER AND
DISTRIBUTE FUNDING.
IN A RESPONSIBLE COST EFFECTIVE
MANNER THAT WILL PRIORITIZE
SOLUTIONS FOR THOSE CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE MOST IMPACTED.
BY UNSAFE IN ON AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER.
IN DEVELOPING THE FUND
EXPENDITURE PLAN THE WATER BOARD
MUST CONSULT WITH AN VICE YOUR
GROUP MADE UP OF WATER SYSTEM
REPRESENTATIVES.
pSERVED BY WATER SYSTEMS IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ADDITIONALLY SENATE BILL TWO
HUNDRED SPECIFIES THE NARROW.
ALLOWABLE USES OF THIS FUNDING
TO ENSURE FUNDS ARE SPENT IN A
TRANSPARENT AND COST EFFECTIVE
MANNER THAT ADDRESS THE ROOT
BARRIERS TO PROVIDING SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER. TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THE FAMILIES FROM COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT SAFE WATER ALONG WITH
THE MORE THAN EIGHTY ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS IN OUR COALITION.
MY CO AUTHORS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAID WHERE TO GARCIA AND RICHARD
BLOOM.
ALL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS HISTORIC
MEASURE.
IN MISTER CHAIR WITH YOUR
PERMISSION OULD LIKE 2%. TWO
WITNESSES FOR THEIR ADDITIONAL.
SUPPORTIVE COMMENTS SO FOR ROUTE
ALL THE BILL'S TODAY WILL BE
ALLOWING FOR MINUTES.
ART FOR PRESENTATIONS BY THIS
THE SUPPORTERS AND THEN FOUR
MINUTES OFFER ANY OPPOSITION --
AND THEN -- COURSE WILL ALLOW --
ADD ON'S FOR FOREIGN AGAINST AS
WELL AS QUESTIONS THEN FINALLY
WILL DO QUESTIONS -- BY THE
COMMITTEE THAT'LL BE THE
PROCEDURE TODAY AGAIN FOUR
MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE FOR
EXTENDED TESTIMONY AND THAT ADD
ONS THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY.
THINGS GOOD AFTERNOON TV SCENE
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY MORE
THAN TEN YEARS AGO WE MET ISABEL
WHO'VE BEEN TINO LE LET ETHEL
KERRY OF BIRTH THOUGH IN ON HIM
FROM THE NEIGHBORHOOD COME
TOGETHER AFTER REALIZING THAT
THEY COULD NOT AFFORD TO OPERATE
OR MAINTAIN.
THEIR ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLAR ARSENIC TREATMENT PLANTS.
THEY FELT TO FIGHT TO MAKE SURE
NO OTHER COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD FACE THE SAME FATE.
YEAR AFTER YEAR WHEN OUR LEADERS
HAVE JOINED HUNDREDS OF OTHERS
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE
DEMANDING ACTIONS THAT TRULY
EMBODY CALIFORNIA'S VALUES
VALUES OF JUSTICE ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY HEALTH
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
SB TWO HUNDRED AS PART OF THE
BUDGET DEAL EFFECTUATE THOSE
VALUES.
IN FACT SB TWO HUNDRED FINDINGS
AND DECLARATIONS THEMSELVES
REINFORCE OUR BEST VERSION OF
OURSELVES CALIFORNIANS IN
ARTICULATE HOW THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND.
IS FUNDAMENTAL TO THAT VISION.
FINDING STATE NO SINGLE GROUP OF
PEOPLE SHOULD BEAR A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THE
NEGATIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSEQUENCES FROM INDUSTRIAL
GOVERNMENTAL OR COMMERCIAL
OPERATIONS ARE POLICIES.
AND SAFE DRINKING WATER
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
PEOPLE OF COLOR THIS FUND PAIRED
WITH APPROPRIATE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS WILL WRITE THIS
FUNDAMENTAL WRONG.
CONCENTRATED ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTAMINATION IN WATER CREATES
HUMAN OF HEALTH BURDENS THE
FINDINGS CONTINUE RESULTING IN
COMMUNITIES WITH HIGHER RATES OF
DISEASE SUCH AS ASTHMA HEART
DISEASE AND CANCER.
THE HUNDREDS OF RESIDENTS THAT
YOU'VE SEEN IN YOUR COMMITTEE
THIS YEAR AND IN YEARS PAST
ADVOCATE FOR SAFE DRINKING WATER
ONE DAY FIGHT INDUSTRIAL
POLLUTION THE NEXT.
BATTLE FOR CLEAN ENERGY THE DAY
AFTER THAT -- AND STILL FACE
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES OF
CHRONIC AND ACUTE HEALTH IMPACTS.
FINDINGS CONTINUE AGAIN THE
CLIMATE CHANGE EXACERBATING THE
WATER IMPACTS ON DISADVANTAGED
ENVIRONMENTALLY BERMAN
COMMUNITIES.
ENHANCING THE LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY OF DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS INCREASES RESILIENCE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
CAROLINE AND HER FAMILY LIVED
WITHOUT DRINKING WATER IN
TOMBSTONE TERRITORY DURING AND
AFTER THE DROUGHT JUST LIKE TENS.
OF THOUSANDS OF OTHER
CALIFORNIANS CALIFORNIA'S POLICY
THAT WATER IS A HUMAN RIGHT AND
DRINKING WATER SOLUTIONS THAT
ADDRESS BOTH INEFFICIENT AND
COSTLY DRINKING WATER DELIVERY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WILL BOTH FURTHER OUR GOALS TO
REDUCE ENERGY DEMAND AND
INCREASE RESILIENCE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE.
FINALLY.
ESTABLISH STATE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE LAWN POLICIES ARE ONLY
EFFECTIVE INSOFAR AS THEY RESULT
IN CHIU PARITY.
AS YOU'VE LIKELY HEARD IS A
MUSCLE ARENA SAY ALLOW WAS VIA
WITHOUT THE FUND AMOUNT MENTAL
ELEPHANT TO A SAFE AND HEALTHY
NEIGHBORHOOD.
THERE CAN BE NO ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE SB TWO HUNDRED
REPRESENTS A HUGE STEP FORWARD
FOR JUSTICE FOR EQUALITY FOR
ACCESS AND FOR RESILIENCE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
BILL [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE WE CAN ALLOW ONE MORE MINUTE --
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF AND THE
DEFERRED TO MY WHEN THIS
JONATHAN NELSON WITH THAT
COMMITTEE WATER CENTER WITH ME
AS WITH THE HERNANDEZ ONE OF OUR
INCREDIBLE COMMUNITY PARTNERS WE
JUST WANT TO SAY THE ON BEHALF
OF THE COALITION FOR SAFE AND
FOUR WHEEL DRINKING WATER FIND.
THAT WE WOULD NOT BE HERE BUT
FOR THE TIRELESS LEADERSHIP.
OF SENATOR MINING AS WELL AS
MANY MANY OTHERS AND THAT THE
SAFE WATER BUDGET COMPROMISE
DEVELOPED BY THE BIG THREE WILL
LITERALLY CHANGE THE LIVES OF
ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS WITH
THAT.
I'LL TURN OVER TO LUCY HERNANDEZ
MY NAME IS LESLIE HERNANDEZ
ENOUGH FROM WAS GOSHEN AND
TULARE COUNTY I'VE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR SAFE DRINKING
WATER FOR OVER ELEVEN YEARS.
AND AS A MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER
I KNOW HOW IT IS TO BELIEVE IN
AND FEAR OF OUR CHILDREN GETTING
SICK FROM DRINKING ON SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
SO I ASKED TO PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS AND PASS THIS BILL AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE. TO TO BETTER OUR
LIVES AND OUR COMMUNITIES IT'S
B. TWO HUNDRED WILL HELP
EVERYBODY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU WHEN YOU'RE WELL ON
YOUR MINUTES.
ALL RIGHT -- COULD I ASK THE
SERGEANTS TO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AGAIN THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- WE'VE HAD TESTIMONY
NOW WILL HAVE THE ADD ONS PLEASE
GIVE YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE A CROWD.
CINDY TECH WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. TEN OF US THAT HAD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION ALSO EXTREMELY
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT AND WE
THANK THE LEGISLATURE IN A
PARTICULAR SENATOR MINING FOR
HIS TIRELESS WORK TO GET THIS
OVER THE FINISH LINE.
JUSTIN SCARRED WITH CALIFORNIA
WATER SERVICE A PROUD SUPPORTER
OF SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED
CENTER MINING THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT PEOPLE ON THE GROUND HE
MADE THIS HAPPEN I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME.
WE ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MONEY AND ALSO
THE GOVERNOR I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS RUTH
MARTINEZ DO CORE CALIFORNIA I'M
AND TULARE COUNTY AND I HAVE WE
HOPE EVERYONE WILL SAY HI TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WITH A FIVE IS A VERY.
ARE GIVING UP BY ALLIES SEVEN
WILL SIMPLE ELECTIVE POSSIBLY.
THE OF THE OF THIS BUT I WILL
GET THOSE MOST.
THE FIRST THE GOVERNOR ONE OF
THE SYSTEM WOULD ADMIT THE
PHONES WERE GOING TO OPEN UP TO
FIND THE REST.
HI MY NAME IS BECKY CAN DATA
THEM FROM SEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND
TULARE COUNTY.
AND HI MY NAME IS BUT THE FABULA
FROM OUR BEEN CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT SB.
TWO HUNDRED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JASON OCCURRED
WITH IT'LL STING GILBERT ROPES
AND SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT
ALSO IT'S PART.
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS DEREK
OFTEN HAPPILY CALIFORNIA CITIES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU CENTER
MONEY.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LEON TRITON
ON BEHALF OF WATER FOUNDATION
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. TO GET
CHOKED UP.
INSTEAD IT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
TRICIA KAREN JR WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH IN CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT.
SEPTEMBER TWO HELLO AND SALAS
WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
TRUCKS PART.
MISS CHAIR MEMBERS PAUL EUROPE
HAVE THE TULARE COUNTY BOARDS TO
REG INSTRUCTS BOARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOWING HE CHECK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA FRESHFORD ASSOCIATION --
CALIFORNIA DERRY'S INNKREIS
COMMISSION STRAWBERRY COMMISSION
VARIOUS OTHER AG ENTITIES IN
SUPPORT.
CARE TO SO ON BEHALF OF CERES
AND SUPPORT.
DANNY MERKLEY CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU IN SUPPORT.
JUST MONTH THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT
HEALTH DIRECTORS THRILLED AND IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST MARLENE DO MAIN WITH THE
EAST BAY MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT VERY PLEASED TO BE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL COATS WITH
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAROLYN JENSEN WITH KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF A HOBBY
WATER AGENCY AND WESTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
SPENCER SACKS THE VOCAL GROUP ON
BEHALF OF KERN COUNTY WATER
AGENCY SAN MARINO VALLEY MINUTES
WATER AGENCY.
AND THE LONG BEACH WATER
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ANTHONY
MILLION ON BEHALF OF MESA WATER
DISTRICTS AND YOUR VALUE
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER AGENCY IN
VARIOUS ACT CLIENTS THAT SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
NOT A MEMO ON BEHALF OF THE
CONTRA COSTA WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
GAIL DEL HAT WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE'RE HERE
IN SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADAM ROBIN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTENOON WAS THOMPSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
JENNIFER COMPETE ON BEHALF OF
THE MONTEREY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
ALEXANDER THE RUN REPRESENTING
AS HE ARE YOU CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IS STRONG
SUPPORT.
SUSAN LITTLE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP IN
SUPPORT.
PLEASE THAT BAND LATE BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT.
MORGAN WITH FRIENDS OF THE LA
RIVER IN SUPPORT.
SCHERING GUNS ALL OF HIS ON
BEHALF OF ANTELOPE VALLEY EAST
KERN WATER AGENCY IN SUPPORT.
DON GILBERT FOR SAN FRANCISCO PC
SUPPORTING.
WE KEEP A CROWDED WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
ALEXANDRA CHARLES REPRESENTING
THE LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
AARON RODRIGUEZ WITH UNION A
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CHRISTY V<c.cyan> WITH THREE</c>
VALLEY'S MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
RYANAIR JACKING WITH SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL WATER THIRTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SOUTHERN AND WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CAN BE REDONDO SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
TELL ME MAKE BASED SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES STRONG SUPPORT.
JAMIE MARK AND WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
DEAL RICHTER FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
I BE BETTER BRUSH WITH THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WATER THIRTEEN
SPORT.
YOU'RE ALSO BEHALF THE CITY
SANTA ROSA IT'S PART.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MERION
WARMER DOWN ON BEHALF OF RURAL
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR BATH A LOSS ON
BEHALF OF INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY A CUCAMONGA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR GREG MORE SOMEONE
ELSE OR VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD -- ANY IN OPPOSITION.
I WAS A PERSONAL RECORD -- SO
BEFORE I AS FOR COMMITTEE OUR
COMMENTS -- I WANT TO JUST --
REINFORCE THAT THERE ARE THREE
AMENDMENTS -- WHICH THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ONE IS
WE'VE ADDED URGENCY CLAUSE.
SECOND THE SPEAKER AND PRESIDENT
PRO TEM IS ADDED AS CO AUTHORS
AND THEN WE'VE MADE ONE
TECHNICAL CHANGE.
AND THAT IS ALL FINE WITH THE
AUTHOR.
OF FINE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK THANK YOU.
WELL WASN'T OUR WORK.
BUT WE WE APPRECIATE IT ANYWAY
AND LIKE BEING APPRECIATED.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'VE HEARD FROM
SUPPORT NOW POSITION I'M JUST
GOING TO REMIND PEOPLE.
THAT I KNOW THERE ARE CERTAIN
PEOPLE.
WHO ARE IN THIS ROOM WHO?
DID NOT LIKE THE WAY THIS BILL
WAS FUND.
BUT WE HAVE A VOTE ON THAT THAT
OCCURRED IN THE ASSEMBLY A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO -- AND PEEP
AND ANYBODY IS ENTITLED TO VOTE
THE WAY THEY WANT TO VOTE BUT
I'D LIKE YOU.
TO PRIMARILY CONSIDER THE FACT
THAT THIS IS A WAY THAT WE
ASSURE CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR
THE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE IT.
THAT'S WHAT THIS COMMITTEE IS
[inaudible]
FOR THE OUR AGAIN YOU'RE GOING
TO VOTE THE WAY YOU'RE GOING TO
VOTE BUT I WOULD SAY -- PLEASE
VOTE WITH THAT CONSIDERATION
RATHER THE CONSIDERATION OF HOW
WE'LL ULTIMATELY FUNDED THIS.
THROUGH THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT COMMITTEES --
EXCUSE ME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER QUE HAN.
YOU WERE FIRST THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
I'M.
SO.
THE CHAIR TOUCH A LITTLE BIT ON
HOW THIS IS FUNDED WE HAD A
HEARING.
EARLIER IN THE YEAR ON CLEAN
DRINKING WATER I THINK THAT.
THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE THE ENTIRE
BODY WANTS TO GET CALIFORNIA.
TO SUPPORT CLEAN DRINKING WATER
FOR EVERYBODY IT'S A TRAVESTY
LEAVE ANYWHERE IN OUR STATE WERE
CHILDREN CAN'T SAFELY BAY OF IN
THE WATER -- AND SO I COMMEND
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS FOR
GETTING US THERE BUT I HAVE TO
SAY THAT I REMAIN CONCERNED THAT
WE HEARD IN THAT FIRST HEARING
THAT.
THERE AT LEAST 30% IF NOT MORE
OF THE PROBLEM THAT HAS BEEN
CREATED HAS BEEN CREATED BY
POLLUTION.
AND BY PEOPLE WHO HAVE POLLUTED
OUR WATER.
AND THAT THIS BILL LET THEM OFF
SCOT FREE [inaudible]
AND THAT.
YOU KNOW I JUST WONDER HOW
ALTHOUGH IT IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO TO CLEAN THE WATER AND GET
CALIFORNIANS TO CLEAN THE
DRINKING WATER AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT.
HOW WE MOVED TO A PLACE WHERE WE
NO LONGER HAVE PEOPLE POLLUTING
OUR WATER IN PUTTING US IN THIS
POSITION WHEN WE LET THEM OFF
SCOT FREE?
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
THROUGH THE CHAIR.
FIRST I DISAGREE WITH THAT
CHARACTERIZATION NOTHING IN THIS
BILL CHANGES EXISTING CALIFORNIA
LAW WITH RESPECT TO ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST POLLUTERS.
THROUGH THE STATE WATER BOARD
THROUGH THE REGIONAL WATER
BOARDS -- THROUGH PRIVATE CIVIL
ACTIONS PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
NOTHING IN THIS LEGISLATION
CHANGES ONE IOTA EXISTING.
RECOURSE TO LEGAL ENFORCEMENT
INTO STATE ENFORCEMENT OF CLEAN
SAFE DRINKING WATER LAWS NOTHING
NOTHING CHANGED IN HERE WITH THE
FIRST PART OF YOUR QUESTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I APPRECIATE IT
I THINK THERE HAS BEEN SOME
CONFUSION ABOUT THE NEXUS WITH
USING G. G. R. OF FUNDING FOR
THIS.
IN HERE'S HOW I WOULD RESPOND
THAT WOULD DRAG MEMBERS TO PAGE
NINETEEN OF THE BILL -- OUR
ASSOCIATE FROM [inaudible]
LEGAL COUNSEL.
MORE OR LESS.
SHE'S OUR LEGAL COUNSEL THEM.
LIMIT CHANGES EXACERBATING THE
WATER IMPACTS ON DISADVANTAGE IN
ENVIRONMENTALLY BURDENED
COMMUNITIES BY REDUCING SURFACE
WATER FLOWS ACCELERATING
DECLINING GROUNDWATER BASINS AND
CONTRIBUTING TO INCREASING
CONCENTRATIONS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
KAMAN CONTAMINATION.
THE LANGUAGE GOES ON BUT TO ME
THIS IS NOT A STRETCH AT ALL WE
I THINK MANY OF A C. G. G. R. F..
TO PROTECT US FROM FUTURE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE THE CURRENT
IMMEDIATE VICTIMS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THIS IS USING R. G. G. R. F.
FUNDS FOR FIRST AID EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TO VICTIMS AND FOR
THOSE WHO SAY WE SHOULD ONLY USE
THAT MONEY TO LOOK TO FUTURE.
POLLUTANTS TO FUTURE GREENHOUSE
GAS GASES OR DISMISSIVE OF
VICTIM COMMUNITIES TODAY THE
SCIENCE IS CLEAR.
AND I BELIEVE.
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS WOULD
BRING THAT FIRST AID TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND I THINK I MEAN
THROUGH THE CHAIR I THINK IT'S
CLEAR IN THE ANALYSIS TALKS
ABOUT THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE -- MADE SURE
THEY DID YOUR OF COULD BE USED
FOR ZILLIONS SEE FOR THINGS
BEYOND WHAT IT WHEN ITS ORIGINAL
FORM WAS CONTEMPLATED FOR AND I
AGREE I THINK THIS FITS WITHIN
THAT I GUESS MY CONCERN REMAINS
THAT YES WE HAVE REGULATORY LAWS
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO STOP THE
POLLUTION.
IN OUR WATER CLEARLY THEY AREN'T
WORKING.
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE AND SO YOU
KNOW I STILL THINK IT DOESN'T
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT 30% OF
THIS PROBLEM WAS CAUSED BY
POLLUTERS AND A 100% IS BEING
PAID I DO DRAFT.
AND IF 30% WERE BEING PAID OUT
OF A DIFFERENT SOURCE THE NOT
30% OF DO YOU HAVE TO GO TO
CONTINUE TO DO THE GOOD WORK
THAT YOU JEFF IS INTENDED -- FOR
IN ADDITION I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT OF THESE FUNDS THIS IS
A CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION WE'VE
DONE THAT BEFORE AND WE'VE SEEN
WHAT.
PICKLE THAT HAS GOTTEN US IN --
AND I GUESS I'M CONCERNS THAT
APPROPRIATING THESE FUNDS IN A
CONTINUOUS FASHION WITHOUT
PROPER OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT
IT IS ACHIEVING THE GOALS WE SET
FOR IT IS -- SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE A PART OFTHE PACKAGE
THE BILL THAT WE HAD PASSED OUT
IS COMMITTEE THAT RELATED TO
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY I
UNDERSTAND IT'S BEEN HELD.
IN IS NOW TO YOUR BILL AND
SEEING AS WE ARE DOING THIS ON
AN EMERGENCY BASIS I WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW THAT WE ARE ALSO.
MAKING SURE THAT THESE FUNDS ARE
BEING USED PROPERLY ON EMERGING
FASHION AS WELL THANK YOU.
AND I WOULD SAY I SHARE THAT
CONCERN IN PRIORITY.
AS MUCH IF NOT MORE THAN YOU DO
BECAUSE OUR GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE
THESE FUNDS.
ACHIEVE THE INTENDED PURPOSE
BUILT INTO THE BILL THAT WILL BE
VOTED ON TODAY.
INCLUDES AN ANNUAL ACCOUNTING.
AN ANNUAL OVERSIGHT AND
REPORTING TO THE LEGISLATURE SO
I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE HAVE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISMS BUILT
INTO THIS THE WATER BOARD WILL
BE ACCOUNTABLE. TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE AN ANNUAL
REPORT NOT ONLY OF THE PLAN
THAT'S DEVELOPED FOR
EXPENDITURES BUT ALSO HOW FUNDS
ARE EXPENDED AND LET ME ADD TO
THAT THAT SHOULD ANY OF YOU HAVE
A CONCERN -- I CAN HOLD A
HEARING.
ANY TIME.
WELL IF YOU IF ANY OF YOU BRING
THAT CONCERN TO ME AND MY
QUESTION IS GIVEN IN IT'S A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION WITH
THAT WHAT DO WE DO WITH THAT
REPORT WHAT IF WE FIND THAT THE
WATER ISN'T BEING CLINTON THE
WAY WE ANTICIPATED THE
APPROPRIATION IS CONTINUOUS
WITHOUT QUESTION.
I GUESS THAT WOULD BE A QUESTION.
THE LEGISLATURE OWES HOLDS THE
POWER TO COME.
EITHER THROUGH THE BUDGET OR
THREE SEPARATE LEGISLATION IN
ACCOUNTABILITY TO PULL AGENCIES
IN FRONT OF US.
YOU COULD CHANGE THE FUNDING
MECHANISM THROUGH FUTURE
LEGISLATION IF ACCOUNTABILITY
SHOWS.
THERE'S SOME KIND OF A GREGIS.
MISAPPROPRIATION OR MISDIRECTION
I WOULD HOPE WE WOULD ALL ENTER
THIS TODAY WITH THE CONFIDENCE
THAT WHAT WE'VE ACHIEVED IS
HISTORIC BUT IT'S NOT FULFILLED
INTEL THE CLEAN DRINKING WATER
IS COMING OUT OF THE TAP.
OF PEOPLE LIKE OUR WITNESS TODAY
THAT WILL BE THE MEASUREMENT OF
SUCCESS.
I WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR THIS
I KNOW THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
WILL AND I WOULD EXPECT EVERYONE
IN THE LEGISLATURE WOULD WANT.
TO I WOULD LOOK AT IT A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY TODAY THROUGH THE
LANDS OF AN ACHIEVEMENT.
THAT IS ADDRESSING SOMETHING IS
GONE UNADDRESSED SINCE THIS
LEGISLATURE DETERMINED THAT
ACCESS TO CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER IS A HUMAN RIGHT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'VE
ESTABLISHED THE RIGHT.
WE'VE GONE FOR YEARS WITHOUT
FULFILLING THAT COMMITMENT.
THIS BILL TODAY SENATE BILL TWO
HUNDRED IS A GIANT STEP FORWARD
TO GETTING CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER. TO OVER ABOUT A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS SHARE.
I THANK YOU CEREMONY FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS ISSUE -- LIKE A
ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE INDICATED TO YOU GOT
THIS ACROSS THE FINISH LINE AND
SO I MIGHT MY RESPECTS IT TO YOU
I WILL BE VOTING FOR THIS BILL
AND EIGHT YOU KNOW I ALONG WITH
THAT MY COLLEAGUE.
MS BARRICADE HAND I I'M NOT.
TO YOU KNOW COMPLETELY HAPPY
WITH ALL ASPECTS OF IT BUT YOU
GOT IT DONE AND I I THINK LIKE
YOU INDICATED THE BOTTOM LINE IS
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE.
CLEANED -- AND SAFE DRINKING
WATER FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
SO -- YOU DESERVE A YOU KNOW THE
THE THE THE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT AND
THE RESPECT FOR FOR CHAMPIONING
THIS.
YOU KNOW I I WANT -- TO YOU KNOW
MAKE IT CLEAR FOR THE RECORD AS
I DID ON THE FLOOR THE STATE
ASSEMBLY THAT -- AYE I DO NOT
PART OF THE THE GREENHOUSE GAS --
FUND -- YOU KNOW RATIONALIZATION --
BUT WE HAVE CROSS THAT BRIDGE
AND AND YOU KNOW THIS IS THE
LEGISLATURE AND SOMETIMES -- THE
THE PROCESS IS MESSY BUT TO THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WE GET IT
DONE -- I ALSO SHARE -- MS
BARRICADE ANSWER CONCERNS --
THAT -- BOTH OF US WE REALLY.
GRILLED MISTER -- GARCIA ON YOU
KNOW WHY IS IT THAT POLLUTERS
SHOULD THE YOU KNOW WOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO PAY MORE FOR THE
CLEAN UP OF THE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER AND AND YOU INDICATE I
BELIEVE I HEARD YOU -- CLEARLY
THAT THIS DOES NOT PREVENT US
FROM GOING FORWARD -- CONTINUING
TO WORK TO TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
POLLUTERS PAY -- FOR THE THE
PROBLEM THAT THEY'RE CREATING
AND AND SO I THINK THAT IS --
YOU KNOW OUR CHALLENGE GOING
FORWARD -- YEAH I I JUST WANTED
TO DO A AND AND I I I HOPE THAT
YOU WILL -- CONTINUE -- TO HI I
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
ON HOW DO WE GET THE POLLUTERS
TO PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE
ESPECIALLY WHERE.
WE'RE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- IN
NOT ONLY THE GREENHOUSE GAS.
OF FUNDS BEING USED BUT ALSO THE
GENERAL FUNDS -- THAT -- YOU
KNOW.
WE SHOULD HOLD THOSE THAT ARE
CAUSING THE PROBLEM.
ACCOUNTABLE OKAY THIS SENATOR IS
HAS I THINK ANSWERED BOTH OF
THOSE QUESTIONS AND SO IF YOU
HAVE MORE TO ADD YOU CAN DO IT
YOUR CLOTHES BUT I THINK YOU'VE
ANSWERED BOTH OF THOSE QUESTIONS.
A MISTER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
CENTER MONEY OUT.
WANT TO COMMEND YOU ON YOUR
EFFORT ON THIS FIGHT -- WE
HAVEN'T ALWAYS BEEN ON THE SAME
SIDES OF IT.
AND I DID VOTE NO AGAINST THE
TRAILER BILL BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK THE G. G. R. F. ON THE WAY
THAT IT WAS DONE TAKING THE
AGRICULTURAL MONIES AWAY -- WAS
THE APPROPRIATE WAY.
HOWEVER YOU AND I BOTH SHARED
THE PASSION TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT GET OVERLOOKED.
GET THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
NEEDED.
THIS IS BEEN A LONG HARD FIGHT
FOR MULTIPLE YEARS -- I KNOW THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL WITH
COMMUNITY WATER WE'VE GONE ROUND
AND ROUND.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY IT'S
ABOUT PUTTING PEOPLE BEFORE
POLITICS IN GETTING IT DONE FOR
THE COMMUNITIES.
I'M JUST HAPPY IT'S NOT A TAX SO
I WILL BE VOTING.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
MADAM VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
SENATOR MINING I I THINK.
WE ALL AGREE ON WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE I
THINK WHERE WE HAVE SOME
DISAGREEMENT AS THE FUNDING THAT
IT'S THAT IT'S BEING USED -- I
REALLY AM HAVING A HARD TIME
UNDERSTANDING THE JUSTIFICATION
FOR USING CAP AND TRADE FUNDING
FOR AN ISSUE LIKE THIS AND I
WONDER -- IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK TO THAT AT ALL BECAUSE I'M
SURE YOU HAVE.
HEARD THE COMMENTS OUT THERE
THAT THE STATE HAS A BUDGET
SURPLUS -- WHY NOT TAP INTO THAT
RATHER THAN USAGI OF FINES WHICH?
IF YOU ASK ME IT'S A VERY WEAK
LINK TO SUGGEST THAT THIS
PROJECT WOULD REDUCE.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IT'S A
IT'S A BIG STRETCH SO WHAT WOULD
YOU JUST CARRIED IT -- EXPAND ON
THAT BEAT BEFORE I HAVE A COUPLE
OTHER QUESTIONS SURE THINK WELL
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
IN.
AGAIN TO ME IT'S NOT THAT BIG A
STRETCH THE G. G. R. FUND.
WELL IT'S DESIGNED TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
IT'S ALSO.
PERFECTLY WITHIN THE AMBIT OF
THAT FUNDING TO PROTECT VICTIMS
OF CURRENT CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS.
IT'S NOT ME IT'S SCIENCE THAT
LINKS CONTAMINANTS IN WATER
SYSTEMS TO DROUGHT DROUGHT
CAUSED BY CLIMATE CHANGE WITH
RESPECT TO KNOWN POLLUTERS
NOTHING IN THIS BILL PREVENTS
ENFORCEMENT OF EXISTING LAWS AND
REGULATIONS.
NOTHING PREVENTS THIS
LEGISLATURE FROM CREATING NEW
LAWS AND REGULATIONS ARE FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO CHOOSE TO GO
AFTER POLLUTERS ALL OF THAT NONE
OF THAT IS COMPROMISED BY THE
LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL.
BUT I THINK MORE BACK TO YOUR
PARTICULAR QUESTION ABOUT THE
NEXUS WE MAY HAVE TO AGREE TO
DISAGREE ON THAT.
I BELIEVE MUCH OF THOSE WHO LOOK
TO G. G. R. F. IS PROTECTING US
FROM FUTURE IMPACTS.
ARE IGNORING THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT OUR CURRENT VICTIMS THIS
BILL.
PRIORITIZES THOSE COMMUNITIES IN
IT IT CREATES A RECURRING FUND
FOR TEN YEARS ONLY.
THAT WE CAN'T PREDICT WHAT
HAPPENS TO OUR GENERAL FUND
BUDGET OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
THIS GUARANTEES THAT THE
INTENDED BENEFICIARIES OF
ACHIEVING CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER WILL BE PROTECTED
REGARDLESS OF EXIGENCIES.
IN HOMAGE TO WE'VE ANSWERED THIS
QUESTION TWICE THE SAME WAY --
WE DO WANT TO GET THIS BILL OUT
QUICKLY SO WE CAN GET ON TO
OTHER BUSINESS SO WE KNOW YOU
CAN ALWAYS MAKE A COMMENT I'M
JUST SAYING HE'S ANSWERED IT
TWICE ALREADY.
IF YOU NEED TO SAY ANYTHING MORE
I CAN SAY IT WAS CLOSE.
NOW IT'S FINE GOING TO YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO SAY I'M FINE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WAS TELLING HIM TO BE
QUIET YOU.
I GET IT ALL RIGHT -- SO.
WE HAD AB ONE HUNDRED WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY THIS BILL
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
WITH SOME WITH CHEN MINOR MINOR
CHANGES BUT I NINETY BRALEY 5%
OR MORE IS EXACTLY THE SAME BILL
WHICH YOU'VE ALREADY HAD SEVERAL
MEMBERS VOTE AGAINST AB ONE
HUNDRED BECAUSE FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS THAT.
THIS IS NOW AB ONE HUNDRED IN
FRONT OF US AGAIN [inaudible]
AND I JUST.
I DON'T KNOW I'M SORRY MR
CHAIRMAN I GUESS YOU JUST DIDN'T
REALLY ANSWER THE QUESTION FOR
ME TO SETTLE MY MIND IN THAT.
THEY USE OF THIS FUNDING JUST
SEEMS WHOLLY INAPPROPRIATE TO
SUGGEST THAT IT WOULD REDUCE
SIGNIFICANTLY ENOUGH TO JUSTIFY
THE USE OF THESE FUNDS AS AS AS
A KIND OF A SLUSH FUND.
THAT SOMEHOW PEOPLE NOT TRUCKING
WATER INTO THEIR COMMUNITY WOULD.
CAUSE A REDUCTION ENOUGH TO
JUSTIFY THIS I THINK IS LIKE
SAYING IF YOU GIVE EVERY.
GIVE EVERY SCHOOL KID AT A
SCOOTER TO GO BACK AND FORTH TO
SCHOOL THEN THAT WILL REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF TRAPS TRIPS ARE
PARENTS ARE MAKING. TO SCHOOL
BACK ON BOARD TO PICK THEM UP
THERE BY I MEAN I JUST I THINK
IT'S A STRETCH.
pIF YOU COULD.
IF YOU COULD MAYBE DON'T WANT TO
I MAYBE CAN'T BUT I REALLY WANT
TO HEAR WHY WE ARE TAPPING INTO
THESE.
FUNDS THESE CAP AND TRADE FUNDS
WHICH ARE SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED
AND PROMISED THAT THEY WOULD GO
TO SPECIFIC THINGS WHY WE ARE
USING THAT RATHER THAN -- AT AND
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS THAT ARE IN
CURRENT EXISTENCE AND THAT WE
COULD SET ASIDE RIGHT.
IT BEGS THE QUESTION DO WE THINK
IT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO COST MORE
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE NOT PUTTING
HER DOLLAR LIMIT ON IT BECAUSE
WE THINK IT'S GONNA END UP.
IF YOU CAN ANSWER IF YOU CAN'T I
UNDERSTAND NOW BUT I'LL BE BRIEF --
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW THAT I CAN
[inaudible]
ADEQUATELY RESOLVE THE CONCERNS
THAT YOU HAVE.
I WILL SAY.
THIS BILL PRESENTS A PATHWAY. TO
ADDRESSING SUCH A CRISIS IN OUR
STATE RIGHT NOW.
AND IT DOES SO WITHOUT RAISING A
TAX FOR A FEE WHICH WAS A STRONG
INTEREST OF MANY MEMBERS OF BOTH
OF OUR HOUSES.
LEADERSHIP HAS AGREED UPON THIS
I'VE OFFERED MY RECENT SWITCH
DIDN'T INCLUDE TRUCKING OF
BOTTLED WATER.
THEY WENT MORE TO THE SCIENCE OF
HOW STRESSED WATER SYSTEMS IN
DROUGHT.
PRODUCE MORE POLLUTANTS.
THAT BECOME A HIGHER PERCENTAGE
OF LESS WATER IN MAKE PREVIOUSLY
DRINKABLE WATER.
UNDRINKABLE THE CLEAR NEXUS TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
IN OKAY SO THAT I DO ASK THAT
ANYMORE QUESTIONS IN FUNDING BE
ASKED BE ANSWERING YOUR CLOTHES
THIS IS THREE TIMES THE SAME
ANSWER.
AND THAT'S OKAY BUT WE NEED TO
GET ON TO OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
QUESTIONS.
I BELIEVE -- LET'S SEE WE'VE
HEARD FROM YOU AND YOU SO THE
NEXT IS -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA.
THANK YOU AND I AND THEN
OBERNOLTE IN ARAMBULA JUST A
COMMENT AND FOR THE SAKE OF TIME
NO ANSWER PLEASE.
I NEEDED BUT YOU NOTICED YOU SET
THAT -- PROGRESS IS GOING TO BE
YOU AND WE HAVE CLEAN WATER
COMING OUT OF THOSE TOUGH TO
THESE COMMUNITIES AND AND I DO.
I I DO SHARE THAT GOAL I THINK.
I WANT TO ECHO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT MY COLLEAGUE AT
GOOD EARLIER ABOUT NOT JUST
HAVING CLEAN WATER COME UP THE
KEEPING THAT.
AS CLEAN WATER NAY AND WITH THAT
THAT WILL BE THE SUCCESS THAT I
HOPE WE'RE WORKING.
TOWARDS I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
HAVE A SYSTEM RIGHT NOW WHERE WE
COULD FINALLY -- TO BAD ACTORS
ARE FOLKS WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE.
BUT I THINK THE SENTIMENT IS
THAT THAT THE SYSTEM HASN'T
NECESSARILY BEEN WORKING THE WAY
IT'S SUPPOSED.
TO OUT THERE AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S WHERE WE KEEP HARPING ON
IT YOU KNOW CERTAIN INDUSTRIES
ARE POLLUTERS -- AND THINGS THAT
WE'VE HAD TIME AND OUT OF HERE
TO GET THE VOTES DONE AND AND
FIND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TO DAY IN
THE ANSWERS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD COME BACK LATER IN THE
CERTAIN.
BUT PART OF THE PROBLEM IS THAT.
THIS YEAR LAST YEAR SHOWS THAT
WE DON'T ALWAYS HAVE THE
APPETITE TO DO THE THINGS EITHER.
AND SO -- I GET WERE OUT TODAY
BUT IT DOES FEEL INCOMPLETE AND
AND JUST FOR THE SAKE OF OF ON
THE RECORD THAT THAT.
IT DOESN'T ALWAYS FEEL
SATISFACTORY IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
DELAY THE SOLUTION THAT THE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE THAT NOW
AND I WILL BE VOTING. FOR THIS
BILL BUT I WOULD BE DISINGENUOUS
IF I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
THOSE ANSWERS ARE NOT ASSEMBLY.
ANSWERS THAT I FIND TO BE TRUE
BECAUSE THE STATUS QUO HASN'T
BEEN WORKING.
AND WE WOULDN'T BE HERE IF I HAD
BEEN AND THE WILL OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE POLITICAL.
THIS IS NOT ALWAYS THERE BECAUSE
IF NOT HERE TODAY I DON'T KNOW
THAT IT'S GONNA BE HERE TOMORROW.
ALL RIGHT -- MISTER MCNULTY AND
THEN MISTER ARAMBULA THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I AM NOT GOING TO
ASK YOU ABOUT YOUR OF ALTHOUGH I
DO SHARE MIKE IN MY COLLEAGUES
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SOURCE OF THE
FUNDING AND I FRANKLY AM
STRUGGLING WITH.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT MERITS A
VOTE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
BECAUSE YOUR SERVING.
A VERY DIRE NEED IN CALIFORNIA --
SO THE SOMETHING I'M THINKING
ABOUT I WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT
AN UNRELATED SECTION OF THE BILL
WHICH IS SECTION.
SEVEN AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
I'M PUZZLED BY BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THE REST OF THE BILL.
SO CURRENT STATE LAW SAYS THAT
IF YOU'RE GOING TO START A NEW
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM.
THE STATE BOARD.
CAN DENY YOUR APPLICATION BUT
ONLY IF THERE'S A FINDING THAT
YOU'RE UNABLE TO FULFILL YOUR
MISSION EITHER FOR FINANCIAL
REASONS OR FOR LACK OF ACCESS.
TO A SAFE DRINKING WATER -- THIS
BILLS PROPOSING TO REMOVE THAT
REQUIREMENT AND LET THEM TO DIET
WITHOUT CAUSE FOR ANY REASON I'M
WONDERING WHAT THAT HAS TO DO
WITH WHAT THE REST OF THE BILL'S
ACCOMPLISHING THIS.
THANK YOU I'M GONNA CHECK THAT
TO OUR WITNESS HELD OUT A LACK.
OF THE MY BEST SITTING THAT. ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS IS THAT SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS JUST SIMPLY.
AREN'T SUSTAINABLE EITHER FROM A
LOT OF QUALITIES PERSPECTIVE OR
TECHNICAL MANAGEMENT MANAGERIAL
AND FINANCIAL CAPACITY.
IN THE PROLIFERATION OF SMALL
SYSTEMS.
IT IS IS JUST EXACERBATES THIS
ISSUE OVER THE OVER THE LONG
TERM ESPECIALLY AND WE'RE LEFT
WITH THE FINANCIAL BURDEN AS A
STATE AND THAT'S THAT'S ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH TODAY.
AND IF WE COULD STEM OF THAT
KIND OF THAT THE PROLIFERATION
STEM THAT TRENDTHEN WILL BE
BETTER OFF ON KIND OF ON THE
MEDIUM AND LONG TERM KIND OF
FINANCIAL PATH.
THE THE BILL DOES.
REQUIRE THAT IF THAT THE THE
BOARD FINDS THAT THERE'S ACCESS
TO A NEARBY WATER SYSTEM.
SO THE THE THE IDEA IS IF
THERE'S A NEARBY WATER SYSTEM
THAT'S A MORE SUSTAINABLE
MECHANISM OF SECURING WATER TO
THAT NEW COMMUNITY IN A NEW AREA.
SO IT IS IT THERE THERE ARE
CONDITIONS ATTACHED AND IT'S ALL
KIND OF IN THE SERVICE OF
CREATING A MORE SUSTAINABLE
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE I
REPRESENT A VERY RURAL AREA THE
STATE ARE THE SECOND LARGEST
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA.
AND MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS
DON'T HAVE THE LUXURY OF HOPE
AGAIN TO AN EXISTING MUNICIPAL
WATER SYSTEM AND A LOT OF TIMES
WHEN WE HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT.
ABOUT WATER SYSTEMS I THINK THAT
RURAL CALIFORNIA IT GETS LOST IN
THE DISCUSSION BECAUSE PEOPLE
THAT REPRESENT URBAN AREAS I
DON'T THINK THAT.
THIS FEASIBLE FOR EVERYBODY SO
IF YOU'RE GONNA MAKE A LITTLE
DEVELOPMENT IN THE MIDDLE OF OF
MY DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE BUT
SOMETIMES THE ONLY ALTERNATIVE
IS EITHER HAVE EVERYONE ON THEIR
OWN WHILE OR YOU INCORPORATE A
SMALL MUNICIPAL WATER SYSTEM OR
MAYBE THIRTY PROPERTIES.
SHARE ACCESS TO A SINGLE WELL
AND THERE'S A SETTLEMENT TO PAY
FOR THAT AND SO I'M CONCERNED
THAT MAYBE THIS IS CLOSING THE
DOOR ON THAT AND WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH THE DOWN THIS ROAD
BEFORE A FEW YEARS AGO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOLD WATER.
AND AGAIN THE PERCEPTION IS THAT
HOLD WATER IS NOT GOOD FOR
PROVIDING SAFE -- AND HEALTHY
DRINKING WATER TO CALIFORNIANS
BUT THE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES OF
A LOT OF THESE REGULATIONS THAT
WE PASSED IS THAT IT MAKES
DEVELOPMENT.
MUCH LESS LIKELY MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE AND A LOT OF THE AREAS
OF THE STATE THAT WE NEED IT THE
MOST.
SO ARE I DO HAVE THAT CONCERN --
BUT I THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING
THE QUESTION IF I COULD JUST
BRIEFLY ADD.
UP THE STATE WATER BOARD IS
CURRENTLY DOING AN ASSESSMENT
THE WATER SYSTEMS STATEWIDE THAT
WILL INFORM THE PRIORITIZATION
OF HOW THIS MONEY.
IS ALLOCATED AND FOCUSED AND
MORE CONSOLIDATION IS ONE OF THE
PRIORITIES WHERE APPROPRIATE.
WE RECOGNIZE IT'S NOT I ALSO
REPRESENT A RURAL AREA SO IF
IT'S MORE THAN A MILE CONNECTION
THAT MAY NOT BE THE MOST
ECONOMICAL WAY TO GO IT DOESN'T
PROHIBIT.
DEVELOPMENT THAT MIGHT RELY UPON.
THE NEWLY DRILLED WELL OR
CONNECTION WITH A SMALLER NUMBER
OF USERS BUT THERE IS GONNA BE A
PRIORITIZATION SWEARS HOUSE THIS
MONEY BEST INVESTED TO SERVE THE
MOST PEOPLE.
AND I UNDERSTAND IT'S JUST THAT
THE LANGUAGE IN CURRENT STATE
CODE SAYS THAT CONNECTION HAS TO
ANOTHER SYSTEM HAS TO BE
FEASIBLE.
AND THERE'S NO DEFINITION OF
WHAT FEASIBLE MEANS SO THIS
FEASIBLE ME IN.
AND OUT LIKE IT WAS FEASIBLE TO
SEND SOMEONE TO THE MOON LIKE
THAT KIND OF FEASIBLE AS FEES
WILL MEAN THAT IT'S NEXT DOOR --
AND I JUST BY BY GRANTING THE
WATER BOARD.
CARD WASH TO DENY THESE
APPLICATIONS I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
GIVING UP LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OVER THE BOARD AND THAT'S WHY I
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU.
I ALWAYS WANT TO GIVE FULL
CREDIT TO MISTER OBERNOLTE FOR
THOROUGHLY READING THE BELL AND
BRINGING UP THESE ISSUES AND
CERTAINLY -- THIS IS SOMETHING
I'D BE GLAD TO TALK ABOUT NEXT
YEAR AND AGAIN I'M WAITED READY
TO HAVE OVERSIGHT HEARINGS.
ARE WHENEVER THIS PROGRAM IS
SUFFICIENTLY OFF THE GROUND AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WANT IT.
MR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
CENTER MONNING FOUR YEARS AGO I
BELIEVE YOU WORKED WITH MY
PARENTS HELPING TO ADVOCATE FOR
FARMWORKERS ON ISSUES JUST LIKE
THIS.
AND JUST OVER FOUR YEARS AGO I
MADE A COMMITMENT TO TRY TO WORK
ON CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR
FARMWORKERS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
TO AND I COULD NOT IMAGINE A
BILL THAT'S MORE IMPORTANT FOR
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE THEN THE
BILL THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE US AND
WANTED TO COMMEND YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON IT.
AS WELL AS OUR SPEAKER IN OUR
HOUSE AND THE PRO TEM WHO HAVE.
REALLY MADE SURE THAT THIS BILL
MEETS THE NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND IS REFLECTIVE
OF ALL PARTS OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A TOUGH SUBJECT MATTER
AND DOESN'T GET DONE EASILY AND
IT TAKES LEADERSHIP FROM.
CHAMPIONS LIKE YOU AND I JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ON IT AND YOUR
COLLABORATION AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING THIS TODAY IN THE
BIG STEP FORWARD THAT IT WILL
MEAN FOR COMMUNITIES LIKE.
ALL RIGHT -- CHAU MISTER MONEY
FOR SENATOR MONEY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE VERY BRIEFLY I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR ALL THE
MEMBERS.
FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT I ALSO WANT
TO SPECIALLY RECOGNIZED SPEAKER
RENDON OWN.
MEMBERS SAID WHERE TO GARCIA AND
RICHARD BLOOM -- PRO TEM ATKINS
SENATORS CABALLERO IN HER TITLE.
IN AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
THERE'S A WILL THERE'S A WAY.
PEOPLE PULLED TOGETHER TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD I ALSO WANT TO
THANK.
ALL THE ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE MANY WHO HAVE MADE YEARS
OF TRIPS TO OUR CAPITAL.
SEEKING.
REDRESS IN SUPPORT I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO VOTE THE WAY THEY
WANT TO VOTE BUT I WOULD JUST
ASK THEM TO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
YOU DID HAVE A CHANCE TO VOTE NO
ON THE FUNDING MECHANISM ON THE
FLOOR.
AND THAT WILL BE FOREVER -- AND
MORE REALIZED AND SO PLEASE VOTE
YES ON THIS BILL.
MADAM SECRETARY WHAT IS THE
MOTION.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER THREE SB TWO
HUNDRED MONNING THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I OUR CAN.
OUR CAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I WANNA TO G..
WITH A TO G. HI SO IT'S NINE
OWNERS EIGHT TWO ONE EIGHT
TWENTY GRADUATION YOU ARE OUT I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALL IF YOU WERE HERE AND
I ASKED YOU TO BE HERE I KNOW
YOU HAVE OTHER COMMITTEES TO GO.
TO I WILL KEEP THIS OPEN LONG
ENOUGH SO YOU CAN ADD ON TO THE
OTHER BELLS THANK YOU LAWLER
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS RIGHT
[inaudible] FOR YEAH I WAS
WAITING.
I ALWAYS DID.
YOU COULD.
THIS IS THE I BELIEVE THE ONLY
SENATOR WE HAVE IN HERE IS
GENDER TRAVEL GYRO.
IF THE OTHER -- FOLKS WHO WANT
TO CHAT COULD LEAVE THE ROOM.
AND WE'LL HEAR CENTER COPLEY ARE
AS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR CAFIERO FOR BEING HERE.
NO -- FIRST TELL UP WELL I STILL
HAVE A MAJORITY OF FOLKS HERE I
WANT TO DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WITH A GOOD ACTORS.
RIGHT.
ON A ROLL.
OKAY OKAY YEAH.
THANK YOU KNOW CAN BE OTHER
THINGS OUT OF THE ROOM OKAY.
GOOD.
OF THE CITY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK HI
[inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
I OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
R. K. HAND I CRISTINA GARCIA
[inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
MATHIS BY.
AND MARK TO GI.
SO THE VOTERS ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE SIX ALL RIGHT SAID THERE
SIX ICE IS OUT WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE OTHER MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT SENATOR -- PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
THERE'S BEEN CONVERSATION
REACHED RECENTLY REGARDING THE
FUNDING TO ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE SAFE AND
RELIABLE DRINKING WATER IN THIS
COMMITTEE JUST SPENT.
A GOOD FORTY MINUTES --
DISCUSSING THAT FUNDING AND AND
THE MECHANISM TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN.
SO IT IT'S AN ISSUE THAT I'VE
BEEN DEEPLY PASSIONATE ABOUT AND
IT'S THE REASON THAT SB FOUR ONE
FOUR IS BEFORE YOU TODAY.
WORKS IN PARALLEL TO THESE OTHER
EFFORTS AND SEEKS TO MAKE
IMMEDIATE AND LASTING GOVERNANCE
REFORMS. TO THE NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED WATER SYSTEM STATEWIDE
THAT THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD HAS IDENTIFIED
THAT CHRONICALLY FAILED TO SERVE.
CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING WATER.
THE SYSTEMS LACK THE FINANCIAL
MANAGERIAL AND TECHNICAL
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
ONGOING CONTAMINATION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES NECESSARY
TO OPERATE HIGH FUNCTIONING
WATER SYSTEMS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE
SYSTEMS ARE IN SMALL RURAL.
CALIFORNIA SERVING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES A SUSTAINABLE
SOLUTION IS NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THIS ONGOING HEALTH AND SAFETY
CRISIS.
TODAY LAWS HAVE BEEN PASSED THAT
ADDRESS VARIOUS ELEMENTS OF THE
WATER ACCESSIBILITY ISSUES
HOWEVER IMMEDIATE AND LASTING
CHANGES ARE NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THE UNDERLYING ISSUES OF THESE
FAILING SYSTEM.
SB FOUR ONE FOUR PROPOSES TO
MERGE THE SMALL NON COMPLIANT
WATER SYSTEMS INTO LARGER MORE
ROBUST PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS THEY
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IMPROVED
ECONOMIES OF CALE.
STREAMLINED MANAGERIAL FUNCTIONS
AND ENHANCED FINANCIAL
CAPACITIES.
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO
COMPLEMENT EXISTING STATE BOARD
CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITY
INCLUDING THOSE IMPLEMENTED BY
RECENT LEGISLATION AS WELL AS
EFFORTS CONTEMPLATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND GOVERNOR AND GOVERNOR
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS AND
IT WOULD ESTABLISH A NEW AND
POWERFUL TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
IN ADVANCE OF THE CONVERSATION
TODAY I HAVE ALSO OFFERED UP
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS IT WILL CROSS
REFERENCE EXISTING POLICY AND
PROCEDURES FOR THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO DEVELOP.
PROCEDURES FOR RESIDENTS OF A
WATER SYSTEM TO PETITION FOR
CONSOLIDATION INTO THE SMALL
WATER AUTHORITY.
I SIGNED FUNDING FOR DISSOLUTION
INFORMATION PROCESSES AND
INCORPORATED ADDITIONAL AREAS IN
MEANS FOR PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
TODAY ARE DANIELLE CODES OF
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
AND DANIELLE BLANCHETTE OF
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL.
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION THE BILL
SPONSORS.
THANK YOU FOR MINUTES PER SIDE
OKAY THANK YOU CHAIR QUIRK AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF SB FOUR
FOURTEEN TODAY.
I WOULD ESPECIALLY LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR CAFIERO FOR LONG
STANDING COMMITMENT TO THIS
ISSUE.
AS INDICATED I'M DANIEL COATS
WITH EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT OR A WATER WASTEWATER
RECYCLED WATER PROVIDER TO
NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS IN WESTERN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
IS TRULY A CRISIS THAT ONE
MILLION RESIDENTS -- CAN'T DRINK
THERE'S WATER FROM THEIR TAPS
DUE TO CONTAMINATION HOWEVER WE
ARE PLEASED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF FINALIZING LONG TERM
FUNDING SOLUTIONS ON ISSUE.
WITH AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN OF
WHICH EASTERN IS IN FULL SUPPORT.
WELL THE LEGISLATORS EFFORTS
OFFER REMARKABLE PROGRESS
TOWARDS ENSURING THAT ALL
RESIDENTS IN THE STATE HAVE SAFE
AND RELIABLE DRINKING WATER.
WE BELIEVE THERE'S IMPORTANT
ADDITIONAL STAFF.
THAT WOULD ENSURE THERE'S A FULL
PORTFOLIO SOLUTIONS AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDE THE MOST SUSTAINABLE AND
RELIABLE RESULTS POSSIBLE.
WHAT THE STATE BOARD HAS
EXISTING POWER TO CONSOLIDATE
SYSTEMS ARE AUTHORITY IS
CONSTRAINED IN SITUATIONS WHERE
THERE IS NO VIABLE RECEIVING
AGENCY?
SB FOR FOURTEEN ADDRESSES THIS
BY ALLOWING CHRONICALLY UNDER
PERFORMING SYSTEMS TO DISSOLVE
AND MERGE INTO VIABLE REGIONAL
AGENCIES.
WITH TECHNICAL FINANCIAL AND
MANAGERIAL CAPABILITIES AND
LOCAL REPRESENTATION.
THIS IS ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH THE
STATE BOARD ACTIVITY ACTIVATING
A STEP BY STEP PROCESS WITH A
DEFINED TIMELINE AND COMPETE
COMMUNITY LEVEL ENGAGEMENT. FOR
MORE ROBUST AND FUNCTIONAL
SYSTEMS.
AS AN ORGANIZATION EASTERN HAVE
LONGSTANDING EXPERIENCE WITH
CONSOLIDATING RIPARIAN SYSTEMS
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
M. AND WE HAVE USED THIS
HISTORICAL BACKGROUND AS TO AND
PROVIDE THE BACKGROUND FOR
DEVELOPING SP.
FOUR FOURTEEN WE'VE COLLECTIVELY
CALLED THE COLLABORATED WITH
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS AND
EXPERTS INCLUDING MUTUAL AND
PRIVATE WATER COMPANIES
ASSOCIATION CLASSICAL
REPRESENTATIVES PUBLIC WATER
PROVIDERS.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCATES
AND STATE FOR REPRESENTATIVES TO
DEVELOP A BILL THAT NOT ONLY
LOOKS.
AT REGION LIES IN FILLING WATER
SYSTEMS IT LOOKS AT THE
UNDERLYING GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
OF THE SYSTEMS TO PROVIDE.
THE LONG STANDING SUPPORT AND
REASONABLE -- USES AND ABILITIES
FOR THE SYSTEMS THE RESULT IS A
BILL THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
INSURED OF THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
WILL HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE AND
RELIABLE DRINKING WATER FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
HOW MUCH TIME FILE ONE MINUTE
AND FORTY SECONDS THAT I'M I'LL
GIVE YOU ANOTHER TENANT?
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DANIELLE BLESSED HIDING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD TO BE
CO SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS OF SB.
FOUR FOURTEEN I'M AS NOTED BY
THE AUTHOR AND ARE CO SPONSORED
BENEFITS OF ESTABLISHING A SMALL
SYSTEM WATER THIRTY ARE NUMEROUS.
ON THIS BILL SAYS OF THE UNIQUE
PROCESS FOR CONSOLIDATION.
NOT A MERE OR SUPERSEDE EXISTING
AUTHORITIES IF THE STATE WATER
BOARD FINDS THAT THE CREATION OF
A SMALL SYSTEM WATER AUTHORITY
IS THE MOST APPROPRIATE SOLUTION.
THE SUBSEQUENT PROCESS IS
LOCALLY CONTROLLED AND
TRANSPARENT WHICH WE BELIEVE
IT'S CRITICAL TO LONG LASTING
GOOD GOVERNANCE WE BELIEVE THAT
CUSTOMERS CAN AND SHOULD FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN DECISIONS RELATED
TO THE DELIVERY OF SAFE DRINKING
WATER IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND THE BILL HAS BEEN DRAFTED TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL STEPS.
WE BELIEVE THAT BELIEVE THAT
THIS TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX WILL
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS SYSTEMS THAT
CANNOT BE CONSOLIDATED THROUGH
OTHER MEANS.
EVEN WITH THE RECENT EFFORTS BY
THE STATE BOARD ON MANDATORY
INVOLUNTARY CONSOLIDATIONS AS
WAS NOTED.
IN THE TESTIMONY ON SB TWO
HUNDRED THEY'RE STILL --
HUNDREDS OF SYSTEMS AND A
MILLION PEOPLE WITHOUT ACCESS TO
SAFE DRINKING WATER EVERY DAY.
OF I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT SB
FOUR FOURTEEN WILL NOT DELAY
EXISTING CONSOLIDATIONS AND IS
NOT MEANT TO REPLACE OTHER
AUTHORITIES.
RATHER COMPLIMENT THEM AND ALLOW
THE WATER BOARD TO SELECT THE
OPTION THAT IS MOST APPROPRIATE
FOR THE SITUATION.
THE TIME IS NOW TO ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES FACING OUR STATE WE
ARE -- WE HAVE A FUNDING
SOLUTION ON THE TABLE AND WE
BELIEVE SB FOUR FOURTEEN PROVIDE
THE SUSTAINABLE PATH FORWARD ON
THE GOVERNANCE ISSUES.
AND WE DRIVE OUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU ARE ONLY THREE SECONDS OVER --
SHOW THOSE IN SUPPORT I SEE A
LONG LINE AGAIN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MERION
WARMER DAM ON BEHALF OF RURAL
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA.
IN CHRISTY FOR ON BEHALF OF
THREE VALLEY'S MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR J.
SENNACHERIB THAT'LL STINK OVER
ROPES AND SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR CHRIS ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE MOORE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'D BE RID
OF BUSH AT THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WATER THIRTEEN SPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BATH A LOSS ON
BEHALF OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCIES CUCAMONGA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN THE
SANTA ANA WATERSHED PROJECTS OF
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
CAROLYN JENSON KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
MEASURE IN THE MILLION ON BEHALF
OF MESA WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAN BE RE I KNOW WITH THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
SPENCER STOCKS THE WELCOME GROUP
OF THIRTY SAN MARINO VALLEY
MINUTES BUT WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSE ADAM ROBIN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROSY THOMPSON
WITH METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON NEW MISTER CHAIR
GREAT MORE SOMEONE ELSE OR
VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
SARS DIVERSE FOR THE MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY
IN THE LOS VIRGINIS WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE OPPOSITION.
WAIT A SECOND WE HAVE MORE
SUPPORTERS IS OPPOSITION COMING
UP.
OPPOSITION VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED YOU HAVE FOUR
MINUTES.
AT THE SCENE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND IT WILL.
WE SUBMITTED A LETTER -- ALONG
WITH CONSUMER ALLIED
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING MANY
WATER CENTER AND CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND WE ARE
EXTRAORDINARILY I THINK IT'S WE
MAY HAVE MENTIONED EARLIER --
THANKFUL FOR THE CENTER COVER
YEARS LEADERSHIP ON DRINKING
WATER AND COMMITMENT TO THE
ISSUE AND ALSO I'VE LEARNED
THROUGH A COLLABORATION WITH THE
CENTERS OFFICE.
AND WITH THE SPONSORS THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE AND
ADDRESSING CONSOLIDATION AND ALL
OF ITS DIFFERENT ITERATIONS --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
US CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
SPONSORS AND THE AND CENTERS
OFFICE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING THIS OPPORTUNITY.
IN THIS NEED WE JUST DON'T FEEL
THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT VEHICLE
AND AS NOTED IN SOME OF OUR
COMMENTS FEEL THAT THE PROCESS
IS JUST TOO CUMBERSOME.
WHICH CAN RESULT IN UNNECESSARY
COSTS AND UNNECESSARY DELAY FOR
SO MANY COMMUNITIES OF WAITED SO
LONG FOR SAFE DRINKING WATER.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JONATHAN NELSON WITH THAT
COMMUNITY WATER SAID ARE -- WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS JUST MADE
THAT WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF SENATOR CAFIERO ON
SAFE WATER.
I'M AND CLEARLY WE'VE SEEN --
THAT WHEN WE COME TOGETHER WE
CAN MAKE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS SO
IN THAT SPIRIT WHILE WE DO HAVE
A CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS BUT WE WILL ALSO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER -- AND
THE DAY THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE
AGAIN IS THAT THIS.
I WHILE THE INTENT IS RIGHT THE
PROPOSAL IS A LITTLE TOO COMPLEX
AND CUMBERSOME WERE WORRIED THAT
WERE GOING TO CREATE A TOOL.
ON THAT GOES IN THE TOOLBOX BUT
THAT DOESN'T ACTUALLY GET USED
AND WE HAVE TO CREATE A TOOL
THAT'S GONNA BE USED.
BECAUSE THERE ARE COMMUNITIES
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY BENEFIT
ROM THIS TYPE OF CONCEPT SO WE
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU --
AND TO GET THIS RIGHT BECAUSE WE
NEED TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARM.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION -- JUST
STAY THERE ARE WHAT THEY MAY BE
QUESTIONS -- MARCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BECKER.
POWER QUE HAND AND THEN ANYONE
AND THEN THE MADAM VICE CHAIR.
SO I I I I HEAR THE OPPOSITION
SAYING THERE YOU WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK.
OF AB BUT YOU KNOW I I KNOW A
LOT OF TIMES.
IF SOMETHING IS PASSED THEN
PEOPLE SAY WELL WHY DO WE NEED
TO DO IS WE WE ARE RATED PAT
WITH DID SOMETHING LAST YEAR.
AND AND SO NOW I AYE CAN YOU
GIVE US A YOUR YOUR BEST
EXAMPLES OF OF YOU KNOW.
WHY YOU THINK THAT THIS MAY BE A
TO COVER SOME -- TO TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
SURE THE WE BELIEVE IT THE
SPONSORS MENTION THAT THE STATE
BOARD DOESN'T CURRENTLY HAVE THE
TOOLS WE THINK THAT THE STATE
BOARD THROUGH ESPECIALLY.
INTO MINISTRY OF A STORY WHICH
IS ACTUALLY -- SOMEWHAT IMPROVED
THROUGH SB -- TWO HUNDRED
THROUGH THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY AND
THROUGH COLLABORATION WITH
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES CAN CREATE --
THIS THIS ENTITY -- AND THAT
THAT MAY BE A BETTER MECHANISM
FOR DOING SO AND THAT THE THE
TOOLS CURRENTLY EXIST AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IN THE
STATE'S IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUND WE ARE
INSURING IN CREATING THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS CLEAN
DRINKING WATER AND THE BEST WAY
POSSIBLE FOR EACH COMMUNITY --
WE ALL KIND OF AGREE THAT
THERE'S NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL SO
I THINK ONE KIND OF FUNDAMENTAL
DISAGREEMENT AS WE THINK THAT
THERE ARE SUFFICIENT TOOLS AND
STATE LAW AND THE ISSUE IS
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE USED.
CORRECTLY CAN A WITH THIS WITH
COME INPUT FROM ALL OF US BUT
ESPECIALLY THE SPONSORS WITHOUT
SO MUCH ABOUT THIS.
THERE'S A LOT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROCESS THERE'S A LOT --
IT'S A BIT OF A GAME OF CHUTES
AND LADDERS TO BORROW A TERM
FROM.
AN COULD COLLEAGUES IN DRINKING
WATER THAT WORK TO COMMITTEE
WATER CENTER FOR MANY YEARS.
THAT THERE'S THE COMMUNITY COULD
BE KIND OF IN GROUP IN WITH A
REGIONAL CONSOLIDATION AND THEN
YEARS DOWN THE LINE IT COULD
THERE COULD BE A DETERMINATION
THAT THAT.
CAN REGIONAL ENTITY IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE OVER THE LONG TERM
AND THE AND THE THE PROGRAMMER
PROCESS IS -- ABANDONED AND ARE
BACK TO SQUARE ONE SO I WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO SEE IS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S A PRODUCT OF THEIR
A ROBUST PROCESS OUT THE AT AT
THE OUTSET.
WERE DOING FEASIBILITY USING THE
STATE BOARDS TOOLS CURRENTLY TO
DO SO VISIBILITY ANALYSIS AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE TOOL THAT
WERE CHOOSING FROM THE OUTSET.
IS GOING TO BE THE SOLUTION FOR
THAT COMMUNITY IN THAT REGION.
AND AND SO WHY DO YOU THINK THE
THE CARD.
IS SO EAGER SEND THAT SB TWO
HUNDRED MAY PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
TOOLS. TO TO TO MOVE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BUT IN THE THE
COMBINATION OF SB TWO HUNDRED
AND AND KIND OF COORDINATION
WITH LEGISLATION THAT'S BEEN
PASSED COME IN PAST YEARS
THERE'S YOU KNOW SB EIGHTY EIGHT
WAS.
IS THE MANDATORY AUTHORITY FOR
REGIONAL AND FISCAL
CONSOLIDATION ALONG WITH SB FIVE
FIVE TWO WHICH WAS ALSO WILK
BILL THAT ALLOWED FOR
ADMINISTRATORS -- AUTHORITY IN
ADMINISTRATOR IN A TO GET NEW
TOO MUCH TO THE WEEDS BUT AN
ADMINISTRATOR COULD FOR EXAMPLE --
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
MANAGERIAL SUPPORT FOR SEVERAL
SYSTEMS AND IT MIGHT BE AND WE
CAN ENVISION THAT THAT
ADMINISTRATOR THAT THAT THE THAT
ADMINISTRATORS A CUSTODIAN TO
GET THE COULD SYSTEMS BACK IN.
PLACE AND THEN THAT CONVERTS
INTO A REGIONAL AUTHORITY FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE STATE'S
EXISTING TOOLS THAT THERE BE A
CONSOLIDATION AMONG THOSE
SYSTEMS -- AND WITH OUT KIND OF
THE PROCESS THAT NOW AGAIN THAT
WE FEEL IS. TOO CUMBERSOME
CURRENTLY AND FOUR ONE FOUR AND
DOESN'T TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
TOOLS WE CURRENTLY HAVE --
THROUGH THE CHAIR MASS THE
CENTER.
TO ADDRESS THE ALL RIGHT SO ARE
YOU HAVE A CHOICE EVENT NOW OR
IN YOUR CLOTHES EITHER WAY IS
FINE WITH ME I CAN DO IT IN MY
CLOTHES.
I'M I'M TAKING NOTES SO I CAN DO
IT ALL TOGETHER FIVE LIKE TO I
MAY HAVE FOLLOWED QUESTIONS ARE
LIKELY HAD RESPOSTA.
MAY HAVE FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
THANKS SENATOR RICHARD CHOI AND
I'M I'M PREPARED TO TALK ABOUT
IT RIGHT NOW SO LET ME JUST SAY
pARE AVAILABLE TO THE STATE WATER
BOARD ARE -- TO FORCE
CONSOLIDATIONS WITH NEIGHBORING --
CONTIGUOUS BIGGER WATER SYSTEMS.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY AT THE READY
TO GO OUT AND TO CONSOLIDATE THE
INDEPENDENT -- INDIVIDUAL WATER
SYSTEMS THAT YOU FIND IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT GIVES A MEDIC.
FORTY UP BUT THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A LAUGH CALL LIKE
PROCESS WHICH INCLUDES PUBLIC
HEARINGS -- PUBLIC KNOWS IT
PUBLIC NOTICE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE COMMENTS -- THERE THEY ARE
THERE IS ALSO A REQUIREMENT THAT
THEY HAVE AN AN OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE FOR REPRESENTATIVES THAT
WOULD BE ON THE BOARD.
AS PART OF THIS CONSOLIDATED
SYSTEM SO RIGHT NOW THEY THEY
MAY HAVE NO BOARD MEMBERS BUT IF
THE CONSOLIDATED THEY CAN BE
FORCED TO HAVE -- UP
PARTICIPATION AND SO ON IF THERE
THE PROTECTIONS THAT ARE USUALLY
IDENTIFIED AS IMPORTANT TO COULD
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS -- THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD AND HAVE
MEETINGS AND TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT IS BEING
PLANNED AND SO -- IT'S IT IT IS
CUMBERSOME BECAUSE THE PUBLIC
PROCESS IS CUMBERSOME I MEAN THE
RULES THAT WE HAVE TO FOLLOW
UNDER THAT.
THE BROWN ACT ARE -- FRANKLY
MOST LOCAL GOVERNMENT PEOPLE SAY
OUR PAIN RIGHT BUT THEY IT IT'S
WHAT PROTECTS THE PUBLIC AND SO --
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
WATER BOARD TO MAKE A DECISION
ABOUT WHAT MAY BE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THOSE PARTICULAR
RESIDENTS?
BUT THEN IT'S IT'S A PROCESS
THAT THAT THAT ON THE LEFT THOSE
HAVE TO GO THROUGH AS PART OF
THAT AS PART OF THE OF MAKING IT
HAPPEN.
AND AND AND FRANKLY I AM IT'S MY
MY BELIEF THAT THOSE THOSE
PROCESSES ARE ARE TO PROTECT
THAT THE RATE PAYERS AND THE
CONSUMERS -- AND AND IF I COULD
I THINK THAT THE ISSUE HERE IS
THAT WE SOMETHING THAT'S GONNA
LAST AND IT'S GOING TO ACTUALLY
WORK AND THAT'S GOING TO BE
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE AND IT'S
THE ECONOMIES OF SCALE THAT
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE.
OUGHT TO BE CONSOLIDATED -- IT
IS NOT A MANDATORY SYSTEM.
IT IS A TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX AND
THE WATER BOARD COULD DECIDE TO
DO SOME OTHER PROCESS -- AND
PART QUITE FRANKLY THAT THE THE
RATE PAYERS MAY DECIDE THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE CONSOLIDATED AS
PART OF AT THE SAID THE SYSTEMS
BUT IT LEAVES THAT IT LEAVES IT
UP TO A PUBLIC AND PROCESS DID
TO MAKE THAT DECISION SO.
SO IS IT CUMBERSOME YES IS IT
GOING TO COST MONEY YES IT IS
BECAUSE ANYTIME YOU'RE GOING AND
YOU'RE DOING A TAKEOVER.
OF OF A SYSTEM -- YOU GOT TO
MAKE SURE YOU'RE PROTECTING --
ALL THE CURRENT RATE PAYERS AND
ANYBODY ELSE THAT WOULD BE
CONSOLIDATED PART OF THE SYSTEM
IS MY SECOND GORON READ WE NOW I
RAN THIS IT WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND GOT IT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND AND AND HE
WANTED TO KNOW WHERE THE MONEY
WAS GOING TO COME FROM IT AND
WANTED THIS TO WORK ON THE FIX.
WHICH IS THE AT THE SP -- ONE
HUNDRED WHICH IS PART OF THAT
PART OF THE FINANCING -- BETWEEN
THE WATER BOND AND THE SP ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS THERE THERE
THERE ARE RESOURCES TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE MAKE THIS UP.
THIS KIND OF CONSOLIDATION
POSSIBLE FEASIBLE.
AN ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE THIS
SUMMER I JUST I JUST WANTED.
TO LET ANYBODY.
AS ONE CHIANG.
ALL THIS GOES NEXT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT YES SO BETWEEN NOW
AND THEN THERE'S TIME FOR
EVERYONE TO WORK TOGETHER WE'VE
JUST PUT OUT SB.
TWO HUNDRED WHICH ADDRESSES SOME
OF THE SAME ISSUES THE BE TIME
TO MAKE SURE.
THAT -- THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH
SB TWO HUNDRED YOU WERE ASKING
BEFORE WE DON'T WANT TO COME
BACK TO THIS AGAIN THERE IS TIME
IT GOES TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
I BELIEVE APPROPRIATIONS.
SO THIS TIME TO WORK ON THIS
BILL BEFORE IT GETS TO THE FLOOR
THROUGH CHAIR THIS IS MY
OPPORTUNITY I DON'T SIGNAL
THAT'S OKAY I'M JUST SAYING I'D
LIKE TO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS NO
THAT'S OKAY YOU CAN ASK ALL THE
QUESTIONS YOU WANT WHAT I WAS
GONNA SAY IS.
THERE IS TIME TO WORK ON THIS
SOME MORE BUT THIS IS MY MY
OPTED NO NO NO I'M JUST TELLING
YOU THERE IS TIME WHICH IS GOOD
THAT YOU'RE ASKING QUESTIONS
THINK THAT'LL HELP YOU DECIDE
WHAT TO WORK ON I APPRECIATE.
ALL RIGHT SO SENATOR -- WHAT I'M
HEARING A LOT IS AT THIS IS
CUMBERSOME HEARING FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THIS IS CUMBERSOME MEN
AND AND -- AND SO A LOT OF TIMES
WHEN I'M DEALING WITH A
COMPLICATED ISSUE I LOOK TO WHO
SUPPORTING AND HIS ACCOUNT'S.
AND IT CONCERNS ME THAT ALL I
SEE ARE THE WATER DISTRICTS THAT
ARE SUPPORTING THIS.
AND AND THE THE ADVOCACY THAT
ARE OPPOSING THIS AND SO.
I I'LL JUST LEAVE IT -- TO AND
AS THAT AYE AYE.
I YOU KNOW IN IN IN THE WORDS OF
A TRIAL LAWYER AYE.
THE THE THE OPPOSITION IS PLAN
OF THAT.
THE RESULT OUT OF MY MIND.
AND I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- LET'S SEE WHO WAS
AND WHO IS NEXT IT WAS SENT.
TO I KNOW THERE'S ONE OTHER
PERSON BEFORE I COME DOWN VICE
CHAIR ALSO WANTED THAT WAS YOU
ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MIGHT ACTUALLY THERE
IT'S OUR RUSSIAN JUST ASK MAYBE
EXCEPT SO IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
ESTIMATED ABOUT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS PROCESS TO HAVE
THAT RIGHT.
I'M NOT I I DON'T REMEMBER THAT
OKAY THE TRUTH ANYBODY I CAN I
CAN TELL YOU THAT WE HAD SOME
NUMBERS FROM THE STATE WATER
BOARD AS IT RELATES TO AB TWENTY
FIFTY BUT WE'VE MADE SOME
IMPORTANT IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE
THINK WOULD REDUCE THOSE COSTS
SO WE FEEL AS THOUGH.
THE COSTS THAT WERE IN THE
LATEST APPROPRIATIONS ANALYSIS
WERE WERE MORE THAN WHAT THE
BILL WOULD ACTUALLY COST TO
IMPLEMENT.
OKAY SO I GUESS YOU KNOW I GOING
BACK AS YOU MENTIONED SB TWO
HUNDRED INCLUDES IN AT THE
ABILITY TO USE THESE TO YOUR OF
FUNDS FOR THESE CONSOLIDATIONS
WE JUST APPROVED WE JUST MOVE
THAT BILL WHICH WOULD ALLOW FOR
UP TO A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO GET.
CALIFORNIANS TO CLEAN DRINKING
WATER IF THIS IS FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS
TAKEN OUT FOR A CUMBERSOME
BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS.
BECAUSE I DON'T HALF THE MONEY.
GOING TO THIS CONSOLIDATION
PROCESS INSTEAD OF GETTING.
OUR CONSTITUENTS TO CLEAN
DRINKING WATER CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THAT SO I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT
AND I CAN I CAN TURN IT OVER --
I THINK IT IS.
IN ACCURATE TO SAY THAT THE SB
TWO HUNDRED MANY WOULD FIND THIS.
THIS WOULD PROBABLY BE A
COMBINATION OF OF FUNDS THAT
COME FROM -- BECAUSE THAT THE
CONSOLIDATION IS ONE THING.
RIGHT WHICH IS THE PROCESS FOR
GETTING ALL OF THEM ON A ON ONE
MANAGERIAL SYSTEM IN TECH
TECHNICAL SYSTEM.
AND THEN THERE'S THE ISSUE OF
FIXING.
THAT SYSTEMS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
PROVIDING CONTAMINATED WATER AND
THAT'S THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT NEEDS TO BE CHANGED OUT AND
IT NEEDS TO BE REPAIRED AND SO --
AT SO YOU HAVE TO DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN THE TWO AND IT'S MY
BELIEF IS AYE RICK RECALLED THE
BOND FUNDING -- WAS.
FOR CONSOLIDATION BUT MAG MAY
HAVE IT BACKWARDS IN THE SB TWO
HUNDRED IS MORE FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE -- AND SO SO
WHATEVER THE AMOUNT IS.
SO LET ME BACK UP AND JUST SAY
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A CURRENT
SITUATION.
WHERE THERE ARE THERE'S NO
MECHANISM? TO FORCE THE
CONSOLIDATION [inaudible]
OF THESE.
SYSTEMS BETTER PROVIDING
CONTAMINATED WATER.
THERE IS NO MECHANISM.
THIS IS A POTENTIAL MECHANISM
AND WE WORKED REALLY HARD AT
CREATING A SYSTEM.
THE TREATS THE PEOPLE.
DEREK CURRENTLY RECEIVING
CONTAMINATED WATER WITH RESPECT.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
BE INVOLVED IN A PROCESS IT'S
GOING TO TAKE OVER THEIR WATER
SYSTEM.
AND THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN A PUBLIC PROCESS.
AND TO BE ABLE TO THEN -- BE
ENGAGED SO THAT THEY CAN ELECT.
BOARD MEMBERS.
THAT'S WHAT'S CUMBERSOME.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO SO I DON'T I DON'T
AGREE WITH THE ANALYSIS THAT
IT'S CUMBERSOME I JUST I THINK
IT'S PART OF A POLITICAL PROCESS
[inaudible]
BUT BUT IT PROVIDES THEM AND
TREAT THEM WITH RESPECT SO THAT
THEY CAN GET THEIR SYSTEM
CLEANED UP SO THAT'S THAT'S ONE
PIECE.
IN TERMS OF THE FINANCING OUT OF
I AM I PROBABLY GOT IT ALL
PULLED UP SO WE CAN JUST GO BACK
HAS.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
ESSENTIALLY ALLOCATING THOSE
RESOURCES OVER FOUR YEARS SO WE
ENVISION A LARGE?
THAT PORTION THAT YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED OVER FOUR YEARS SO
IT'S NOT GONNA BE A ONE TIME.
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION
FROM THE HUNDRED THIRTY OR
WHATEVER FUNDING SOURCES OUT
THERE IT'S GOING TO BE.
ALLOCATED OVER FOUR YEARS AS
THIS PROCESS AND ROLLS.
AND ROLLS AND WHAT I ALLUDED TO
IN MY TESTIMONY IS THAT WE
AREN'T JUST LOOKING AT A
REGIONAL ALLIES A SITUATION
WE'RE LOOKING TO REGION LIES OF
WATER DISTRICTS.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE UNDERLYING
GOVERNANCE WERE ACTUALLY FORMING
NEW WATER SYSTEMS IT'S A NEW
SYSTEM IN THE GUT AND AM.
I KNEW PRINCIPLE ACT SO WHAT THE
BILL DOES IT ESTABLISHES ALL THE
POWERS THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR
THE SYSTEMS TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
WE'VE IT AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS WE'VE HAD
OUTLINED ALL THE TRANSPARENCY
MECHANISMS THAT ARE NECESSARY WE
HAD TO OUTLINE ALL THE ABILITIES
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH.
AND THIS IS DONE THROUGH
MULTIPLE ACTS BECAUSE WE ARE
LOOKING AT CPUC REGULATED WATER
SYSTEMS WERE LOOKING OUT PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS ARE ALSO LOOKING
AT MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES.
SO WE'RE TAKING ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS TYPES
DISSOLVING THEM AND THEN FORMING
THEM INTO A NEW SYSTEM THROUGH A
NEW PRINCIPAL ACT SO IT WELL IT
APPEARS CUMBERSOME.
IS ACTUALLY A ROAD MAP THAT
PROVIDES VERY.
DEFINED STEP BY STEP ACTIONS.
AND I'M SORRY IF I MAY ADD WE
DON'T HAVE TO ENVISION A FUTURE
WHERE SOME SIT.
FOR THESE DIFFERENT WATER
SYSTEMS EVENTUALLY JOINED.
WHERE IT PROVIDING A FUTURE
WHERE THE SYSTEMS ARE TOO LARGE
AND VIABLE AND TRANSPARENT?
SO.
AM I APPRECIATE THAT ACTUALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
GIVING.
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE SUFFERING
FROM THIS CLEAN WATER PROBLEM
CALIFORNIA VOICE AND I THINK
THAT AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
I GUESS WE JUST HAD A ROBUST
CONVERSATION I THINK YOU WERE
HERE FOR IT ON SB TWO HUNDRED
ABOUT ALL OF OUR CONCERNS ABOUT
USING TEACHER OF MONEY. TO GET
TO CLEAN WATER AND THEN ALICE'S
ON SB TWO HUNDRED ABSOLUTELY
SAYS THAT.
PROVIDE THE MONEY IS
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED.
BUT TO THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
FIND THE FOLLOWING CONSOLIDATED
WATER SYSTEMS TO FIND THIS
PROCESS SO AGAIN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT USING DID YOUR OF FUNDS
AND I THINK WE'RE GETTING
FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY FROM.
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AND
TEACHES GIVES ME GREAT PIES.
ALL RIGHT NOT A VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN -- SO
JUST IN LISTENING TO THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT YOUR OWN
COMMENTS ABOUT TREATING YOU KNOW
THESE FOLKS WITH.
RESPECT IN THE COMMENTS OF MY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TALKING ABOUT
THIS BEING A TRANSPARENT PROCESS
THE THING THAT STICKING WITH ME
THE MOST IS IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THESE --
SMALL WATER AUTHORITIES COULD
ISSUE BONDS WITHOUT VOTER
APPROVAL [inaudible]
WHY?
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
CONSOLIDATED YES SYSTEMS.
YEAH THE BILL ENABLES THESE
SYSTEMS TO PASS REVENUE BONDS
AND THAT IS A METHOD I KNOW WHAT
A REVENUE BOND IS WIRE WHEEL
AGAIN IF YOU COULD JUST ANSWER.
OKAY IT'S A METHOD OF FINANCING --
THAT IS WIDELY USED THROUGHOUT
THE WATER AND WASTEWATER
INDUSTRIES.
AND DO YOU HAVE AN POWER THESE
DISTRICTS TO UTILIZE.
ALL THE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX TO
ENSURE THERE IS THE ABILITY.
TO PROVIDE THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE MOST TIMELY AND SENSITIVE
MANNER BY BY PASSING THE VOTERS.
THERE WE ARE SPEAKING OF A VERY
DEFINED AND SMALL UNIVERSE THAT
ARE ABLE TO UTILIZE ALL THE TOOL
BOXES ARE ALL THE TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX THAT CURRENT WATER
AGENCIES UTILIZE.
WE HAVE OVERSIGHT BUILT INTO THE
BILL BY THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE BY THE LAUGH GO.
BY ALL THESE DIFFERENT ENTITIES
TO ENSURE AND AS WAS IDENTIFIED
IN THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE HEARING ON AB.
TWENTY FIFTY AT THIS TIME THERE
IS NO KNOWN DEFAULT ON A REVENUE
BOND.
BUY PULP SO AGAIN I GO BACK.
TO IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE SAYING
AS LONG AS THE UNIVERSE IS VERY
VERY SMALL IT'S OKAY TO NOT GO
THROUGH THE NORMAL PROCESS AND
OKAY TO BY PASS THE VOTERS WHICH
IS NOT THE NORM.
IN ANY OTHER CASE WHEN YOU'RE
ISSUING BONDS AT THE VOTERS HAVE
A CHOICE THAT VOTERS WOULD HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLAW THAT BACK
BUT THEY WOULD HAVE TO DO THAT
WITH THE REFERENDUM WHICH I
THINK IS BACKWARDS IN IS NOT
RESPECTFUL. TO THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO SERVE TO WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS WONDERFUL
IT'S JUST THIS PARTICULAR PART
WHERE YOU'RE SAYING BASICALLY
IT'S JUST GONNA BE EASIER FOR US
TO DO THIS IF WE JUST DON'T
ALLOW THE VOTERS TO WAY AND I
THINK THAT'S INAPPROPRIATE.
AND I THINK IT'S AN ANSWER WRONG.
SOUND [inaudible]
I'M.
ALSO I HAVE A QUESTION DON'T WE
ALLOW ALL THE WATER DISTRICTS TO
DO THIS TO HAVE REVENUE BONDS
ALL THE SEWER DISTRICTS DON'T
THEY ALL HAVE THIS A TOWARD.
MY KNOWLEDGE THAT YEAH I MEAN
CERTAINLY THE CITY OF HEY WHERE
DO WE DID -- REVENUE BOND -- TO
DO OUR SEWER SYSTEM THAT IS PAID
FOR BY SEWER FEES IT'S NOT
REQUIRED TO GO BEFORE THE VOTERS.
OF SAME WITH THE S. F. P. YOU
SEE WHICH AND AND OTHER AGENCIES --
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO FUND THAT
THROUGH FEES.
IT'S IT'S NORMAL HONEST ALL THE
BIG WEATHER DISTRICTS DO IT
[inaudible]
OUR YOUR OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAD A
QUESTION ABOUT THE METHOD ON
WHICH AB FORCIBLY CONSOLIDATE
WATER SYSTEM IS VALUED.
SO THE BILL HAS A SECTION ON
THIS AND IT SAYS THAT TO VALUE
IT YOU DO A DISTRESSED BUSINESS
VALUATION.
WHICH ARE MOST ACCOUNTS WILL BE
FAMILIAR WITH YOU TAKE ALL THE
ASSET YOU SUBTRACT ALL THE
LIABILITIES BUT IT'S GOT.
ANOTHER PART THAT SAYS THAT YOU
ALSO SUBTRACT.
THE COST REQUIRED TO BRING.
NOT JUST THE EQUIPMENT BUT THE
DRINKING WATER TREATED UP TO
STATE STANDARDS.
A ON OUR THAT CAUSED SOME
CONCERN FOR ME BECAUSE IT'S NOT
AN UNREASONABLE SITUATION TO
THINK OF A WATER DISTRICT THE
COULDN'T AFFORD.
THE EQUIPMENT REQUIRED TO TREAT
THE WATER UP TO THE STATE'S
STANDARDS AND THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
DISTRESSED IN THE FIRST PLACE IN
FACT I HAD A MEETING IN MY
DISTRICT OFFICE.
ON FRIDAY WITH BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF A WATER DISTRICT
THAT IS EXACTLY THAT SAME
SITUATION SO I MEAN IF YOU SAY
THAT.
THE A A DISTRICT JUST BOUGHT A
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
EQUIPMENT.
BUT THEY CAN'T AFFORD THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IT WOULD TAKE.
FOR THE EQUIPMENT -- TO TREAT
THE ACROMION REMOVE CHROMIUM SIX
OR URANIUM OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT -- TO SAY THAT THEY ARE
WORTH NEGATIVE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT TO ME
SO COULD YOU TALK A BIT ABOUT
THAT METHOD EVALUATION BECAUSE
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
I GIVE IDENTIFIED THE METHOD --
CORRECTLY BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
IN ANY SCENARIO THERE'S GOING TO
HAVE TO BE -- SOME ENTITY THAT'S
GOING TO HAVE TO BRING THAT
SYSTEM UP TO COMPLIANCE AND SO
SHOULD THAT SYSTEM GET VALUE.
FOR WHAT IS ULTIMATELY GOING TO
HAVE TO OCCUR.
YEAH BUT YOU'RE SEIZING HIS
PROPERTY.
YOU'VE GOT LIKE THESE SMALL
MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES MIGHT
HAVE THEIR OWN SHAREHOLDERS THAT
HAVE MADE AN INVESTMENT IN THIS.
IN THIS WATER DISTRICT AND IT'S
A STATE STANDARD IN MANY CASES
THAT'S FORCING THE FINANCIAL
DISTRESS ON THE WATER DISTRICTS
ARE I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW WE DECIDE AS
A STATE WHAT OUR MINIMUM
STANDARDS ARE.
IF WE HAVE WATER DISTRICTS
THEY'RE HAVING TROUBLE WE CREE
GRANT FUNDS TO TELL THOSE WATER
DISTRICT OUT THAT'S ALL WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE BUT TO SAY. TO
THE EXISTING OWNERS OF THAT
PROPERTY YOU GET NOTHING SEEMS
TOTALLY WRONG TO ME.
WELL I UNDERSTAND YOUR YOUR
POSITION EXCEPT FOR THAT HAD
THEY TAKEN.
CARE OF THE PROBLEM THEN THEY
WOULD BE PROVIDING CONTAMINATED
WATER TO PEOPLE I MEAN THAT
MEANS AND LET ME JUST TELL YOU
THAT MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES IN
MY DISTRICT.
THEY ARE BEING PROVIDED WITH
WATER THAT THEY CANNOT USE THEY
GET CHARGED.
MOM AND IN A COUPLE OF THE OF
THE DISTRICTS IT'S IN EXCESS OF
A HUNDRED DOLLARS SO THEY HAVE
TO PAY FOR WATER THE DATE THEN
CAN'T DRINKING CAN BE THEN.
AND AND IT'S A IT'S A MINIMUM
FEE AND SO PART OF THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE IS HOW DO YOU.
HOW DO YOU CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO INVEST RESPONSIBLY
IN THOSE WATER SYSTEMS ONCE
THEY'VE THEY'VE BEEN THE POINT
WHEN SHE STARTED CONSOLIDATION
PROCESS?
AND IS ARE THEY ENTITLED TO GET
PAID FOR SOMETHING -- THAT THAT
IS NOT NOT MEETING STATE
STANDARDS BY A LONG SHOT I THIS
ISN'T EVEN CLOSE IT'S IT'S BY A
LONG SHOT AND SO -- IT ACT THE
PART OF THE IT'S PART OF THE
REPERCUSSIONS OF IT AND AND WE
WE WE DID IT THAT WAY
SPECIFICALLY SO THAT WE ARE WE
HAD WAITED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THE INVESTMENTS IN IN.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S GOING
TO BE NEEDED.
OKAY SO LET ME PROVIDE YOU A
COUNTER EXAMPLE FROM MY DISTRICT --
I'VE WATER DISTRICT THAT HAS A
CHROMIUM SIX PROBLEM.
AND IT'S NATURALLY OCCURRING AND
THEY DIDN'T USED TO HAVE A
PROBLEM BECAUSE THE STATE
STANDARDS WAS HIGHER DROP THAT
USED TO BE AND AND SO EVERY TIME
DETECTION TECHNOLOGY IMPROVES WE
LOWER THE STATE'S STANDARDS SO
WE'RE NOT LOWERED IT TO THE
POINT WHERE.
THEY HAVE A PROBLEM AND
INVESTING.
THIS PARTICULAR DISTRICT I THINK
WE FOUND A WAY OUT FOR THEM BUT
ORIGINALLY LOOKED LIKE INVESTING
IN THE EQUIPMENT TO REMOVE THEIR
CHROMIUM.
SIX WAS WAS GOING TO BANKRUPT
THE DISTRICT THERE'S NO WAY FOR
THEM TO DO IT.
THE SHARES OF STOCK IN THAT
DISTRICT HAVE BEEN IN -- A
FAMILY FOR GENERATIONS -- WAS
LIKE THE GRANDPA SMITH STARTED
YOU KNOW WHEN THE AREA WAS FIRST
SETTLED TO SAY AND AND THEY MADE
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENT -- IN THE
SYSTEM SINCE THEN TO SAY TO THAT
FAMILY.
THAT YOUR SHARES ARE WORTH
NOTHING BECAUSE OF A DECISION
THAT WE MADE HERE IN THIS
BUILDING I THINK IS WRONG.
SO THE REST OF THE VALUATION I
THINK IT'S FAIR THAT PARTICULAR
PART OF THE VALUATION HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THIS THE
STATE OF REPAIR OF THE EQUIPMENT
HAS NOTHING TO DO.
WITH THE DUE DILIGENCE THAT THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF EXERCISE
BECAUSE LIKE I SAID IT'S A
DECISION THAT WE MADE HERE SO I
I I OUR OUR TO RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE ON THAT POINT -- THAT'S
ONE OF THE BIG CONCERNS THAT I
HAVE THIS WITH WITH THIS BILL
SOFTER RESPECTFULLY THE
OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND IT AND
THE THE SOLUTION TO THAT IS THAT
THEY DON'T GET CONSOLIDATED AND
THAT THE FIGURE OUT ANOTHER
SOLUTION TO BE ABLE TO COME.
AT TO RESOLVE THE CHROMIUM SIX
BECAUSE THIS IS AN OPTIONAL THIS
IS AN OPTION IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
MANDATORY YOU KEEP IT.
HERE YOU KNOW YOU CAN BE YOU CAN
BE CONSIDERED PART OF THE SYSTEM
BUT THERE'S THIS WHOLE PUBLIC
PROCESS THAT PEOPLE CAN EXTRACT
THEMSELVES OUT OF OUT OF THAT.
OUT OF THE CONSOLIDATION SO SO
THERE'S OPTION I GUESS IS THE
POINT IS MY POINT OKAY I'M NOT
I'M NOT TRYING TO CHANGE YOUR
OPINION NUMBER UNDERSTAND.
THAT YOU'RE RIGHT AND I HOPE TO
SOME OF THE ACTIONS WE'VE TAKEN
TODAY CREATE ENOUGH FUNDING.
SO THAT WE CAN SAVE A SMALL
WATER DISTRICTS LIKE THAT.
ONE YES WE REALIZE THAT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF EQUIPMENT WE REALIZE
THAT YOU HAVE TO DOUBLE YOUR
RATES TO PAY FOR THAT WHICH IS A
SITUATION THAT THEY'RE IN.
A HERE WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU A
GRANT TO SOLVE YOUR PROBLEM I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN
BUT WE CAN'T BLAME THE DISTRICT
FOR THAT IT'S NOT THEIR
MISMANAGEMENT THE CAUSE THAT TO
HAPPEN.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S NATURALLY
OCCURRING IN ITS RESULT OF US
LOWERING THE STANDARDS SO -- YOU
KNOW THAT THAT'S MY CONCERN AND
I REALLY WISH THAT THAT PART WAS
NOT IN THE VALUATION
CALCULATIONS.
TO VERY GOOD OUR OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT MùT IT'S BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED A FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR BRINGING
UP A LOT OF ISSUES AND QUESTIONS
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE VERY.
SO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH --
SENATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING IN
ADDITION TO SAY ISSUE CLOSE I
THINK I THINK I PRETTY MUCH HIT
EVERYTHING I AM.
LET ME JUST SAY THAT THAT I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE WITH
THE OPPOSITION -- WE'VE HAD SOME
SOME GOOD CONVERSATIONS -- AND
MY MY GOAL IS TO BE ABLE TO GO
BACK TO THESE -- FAMILIES THAT
I'VE COME TO KNOW VERY WELL WHO
ARE -- WHO REALLY ARE ARE LIVING
IN -- LIVING IN THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD YOU
WOULDN'T BELIEVE READ THAT THEY
TURN ON THE WATER FAUCET AND NOT
BE ABLE TO BE THERE TO DRINK IT.
AND I WANT TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK
TO THEM AND SAY WE HAVE SOME
SOLUTIONS HERE AND THAT'S THE
REASON WE'VE BEEN WORKING SO
HARD ON THIS BILL SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AGAIN
THIS BILL GOES NEXT -- TO A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THEN
APPROPRIATIONS SO IF PEOPLE HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS SUGGESTIONS
PLEASE BRING THEM TO THE SENATOR.
AND HER STAFF -- I AM GOING TO
URGE AND I VOTE -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SB FOUR FOURTEEN GUY AT ALL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS QUIRK.
HI QUIRK I MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NOT VOTING OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I POWER QUE HAN
[inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN
[inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
OKAY HAS THREE NEEDS TO MORE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I SE SENATOR HER TADO
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE YEARS SO PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
SO THE THIS IS THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD INTERIM
GRANTS.
ARM AND I HAVE SOME.
OKAY I JUST WANT TO MENTION THAT
THE REASON THE MEMBERS TO THE
BELL REMOVE ITS JURISDICTION
FROM THE ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENT.
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE THERE FOR
GOES TO ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AFTER THIS COMMITTEE
SAU.
A SENATOR PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS --
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ON SB.
FIVE ONE THREE WHICH WILL HELP
INSURE WATER TANKS REMAIN
AVAILABLE FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE
WITHOUT DRINKING WATER AS A
RESULT OF A TRY WELL.
IN CALIFORNIA OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED FAMILIES HAVE NEEDED
EMERGENCY WATER TANKS AS A
RESULT OF CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC
DROUGHT.
A COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE SELF HELP ENTERPRISES OFFER
ASSISTANCETO FAMILIES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BY INSTALLING
WATER TANKS.
AS A TEMPORARY SOLUTION UNTIL
GROUND WATER IN THE WELLS.
RECHARGES OR UNTIL.
A MORE PERMANENT SOLUTION OCCURS
AS YOU ALTHOUGH GROUND WATER
MOVES MUCH MORE SLOWLY THAN
SURFACE WATER.
AND IT TAKES TIME FOR GROUND
WATER RECHARGE OF WELLS TO OCCUR.
HOWEVER ALTHOUGH THE DROUGHT WAS
DECLARED OVER IN APRIL TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WATER SHORT SHORTAGE
IS A CHRONIC SYMPTOM IN MY
DISTRICT AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND MANY FAMILIES WHO WENT DRY
AFTER APRIL TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN DID NOT QUALIFY FOR
TEMPORARY WATER TANKS.
THIS MEANS THAT MANY FAMILIES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHO RELY ON
WELLS FOR THEIR DRINKING.
WATER ARE STILL IN NEED OF
INTERMARRIAGE TANKS EVEN OF THE
TRIBE HAS BEEN DECLARED OVER.
SB FIVE THIRTEEN CODIFIES THAT
FUNDING FOR WATER TANKS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY HOME IMPACTED
BY TRY WELL OR DROUGHT IT
CLARIFIES THAT STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
MAY SOON PROVIDING FUNDING FOR
WATER TANKS FOR HOMES WITH DRY
WELLS OUTSIDE OF AN EMERGENCY.
DROUGHT DECLARATION.
THIS BILL ALSO CONFORMS TO TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED FOR WATER TANKS AND
INTERNALLY FOR MEASURES IN AB.
SEVENTY FOUR OUR BUDGET BILL
RECENTLY SIGNED BY GOVERNOR YOU
SAM.
UP WITHOUT THIRTY IN THE LAW
THAT ALLOWS THIS PROGRAM TO
ALLOCATE FUNDS TO HOMES OUTSIDE
OF EMERGENCY SITUATIONS.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WILL REMAIN UNABLE TO OFFER
FAMILIES THE COMFORT OF CLEAN
AND SAFE WATER.
THROUGH THESE AND FROM WATER
TANKS ARE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
TAMMY MCVEIGH WITH SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES.
UP WE HAVE FOUR MINUTES FOR EACH
SIDE -- FOR OPPOSITION IN
SUPPORT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY THANK YOU AB.
MY NAME IS TAMMY MCVEIGH WITH
SELF HELP ENTERPRISES AND I JUST
WANT TO THINK CENTER HER
DAUGHTER AND HER STAFF AND JUST
BEING OUR CHAMPION AND LOOKING
OUT FOR THESE RESIDENTS AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
ALMOST A HUNDRED FOLKS WITH OUR
HOMES WITHOUT WATER RIGHT NOW
AND WE ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
TRY AND PROVIDE THEM.
EMERGENCY TANKS SO THESE FUNDS
WOULD ASSIST US I THINK RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE ABOUT A MILLION
DOLLARS TO SERVE THOSE HUNDRED
PEOPLE.
AND SO ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDS
WOULD.
REALLY WORK FOR THEM AT SO ON
BEHALF OF SELF HELP WE DO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I ALSO WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
GUYS THIS STORY -- AND TESTIMONY
OF ONE OF OUR PARTICIPANTS.
DO I HAVE A SECOND.
OKAY ARE VERY GOOD MOVED AND
SECONDED OKAY I'LL WRITE
ANYTHING.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA MAKE ME I CAN
I SHARE MY TESTIMONY.
IT'S UP TO YOU.
YEAH YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU
WANT.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
TO WELL THAT WAS -- ABOUT TEN
MONTHS AGO I RECEIVED A CALL
FROM A VERY FRANTIC WOMAN.
I HAVE A HARD TIME GETTING
THROUGH THE STORY -- HER WELL
I'VE GONE DRY AND EARLIER THAT
SUMMER SHE HAD SHE JUST HEARD
ABOUT SELF HELP ENTERPRISES.
FROM ONE OF THE WATER HOLLERS
SHE DIDN'T KNOW THAT WE HAD
PROGRAMS THAT EXISTED ANIMUS
MISTER LANCE'S THE WOMAN -- SHE
TOLD ME HOW SHE WAS ON A FIXED
INCOME DUE TO HEALTH RELATED
ISSUES SHE HAD TO QUIT HER JOB
BECAUSE HER SON WAS ALSO
DISABLED AND SHE NEEDED TO TAKE
CARE OF HIM.
MS BUT LANCE WAS HOPING TO GET
ON AND ON AND EMERGENCY TAKE
PROGRAM BUT AT THE TIME WE HAD
NO BUTTONS.
MRS BUT LANCE EXPLAINED HOW SHE
HAD APPLIED MULTIPLE FOR
MULTIPLE PERSONAL CREDIT CARDS
AND HAD MAXED THEM ALL OUT JUST
TO HAVE WATER BROUGHT TO HER
HOME. FOR HER AND HER SON.
THIS REQUIRED -- MISS LANCE ALSO
LIVED IN MOBILE HOME IN
RIDGECREST.
AND SO SHE ONLY HAD SOME SO
SORRY SHE ONLY HAD A SWAMP
COOLER.
AND SO SHE REQUIRED EXTRA WATER
JUST TO KEEP THE HOME QUOTE.
MY STAFF AND I WORKED DILIGENTLY
TO TRY AND GET HER.
APPLICATION MOVE FORWARD BUT
WITH A LOT OF PROGRAMS THERE'S A
LOT OF DOCUMENTATION IT'S
REQUIRED SO IT DID TAKE SOME
TIME.
THIS BILL AND HAD TO RELY ON
OTHERS IN ORDER TO GO GET THE
DOCUMENTS THAT SHE NEEDED -- BY
MARCH WE HAD RECEIVED EVERYTHING
AND HAD AN APPROVAL THINK YOU.
HAD AN APPROVAL YOU.
NICE. TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
DRILLING OF A NEW WELL DURING
THIS TIME MISTER LANCE CHOSE TO
USE HER FUNDS. FOR WATER INSTEAD
OF HEALTH CARE.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR MISS BLACK AND
HER SON THE DECISION CAME IN A
REALLY HIGH COST.
IN A MYTH WILL HAVE PASSED AWAY
DUE TO AN MATH HEALTHCARE NEEDS.
SHE LEAVES BEHIND A DISABLED SON
AND A LARGE AMOUNT OF UNPAID
DEBT.
I WANT TO SHARE THIS STORY WITH
YOU.
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO KNOW THE
WORK AND THE EFFORTS THAT ARE
DONE BY SENATOR HEARD HOW DOES
OFFICE AND HER STAFF AND ALL OF
YOU BY LISTENING TO THE STORY
THAN UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE IS
THE HUMAN TOUCH.
MEANS A LOT NOT JUST TO MRS
LANCE'S FAMILY WHO WON'T SEE
THAT WATER.
BUT ALSO TO OTHER FAMILIES WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING THE SAME THING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MOVING
TESTIMONY THANK -- MY FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- FOR THEIR
ATTENTION TO THIS MATTER
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
YES MILAN ABOVE THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH DIRECTIVES WE
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THIS BILL IN
ADDITION TO THE SELF HELP FOLKS
IN THE STATE MANY LOCAL IN
BERMAN HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WENT
OUT AND HELPED.
THE COMMUNITIES WHEN THEY'RE IN
SUCH A DIRE STRAITS SO WE
APPRECIATE A BRING THIS TO YOU
AND IT'S CERTAINLY WILL CLARIFY
THAT THE STATE HAS THE RESOURCES
AND COMPOSITE ON TO BOTH THE NON
PROFITS.
AND THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS.
VERY GOOD ANYONE ELSE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
GLAD TO KNOW THERE ARE NO
SCROOGE'S HERE.
ALL RIGHT -- IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED ARE THERE -- QUESTIONS
BY THE COMMITTEE MISTER MATHIS.
I COULD ALSO SAVE HOW GREAT THIS
BILL IS THIS GOES.
COMPLETELY ONLINE WITH
EVERYTHING -- YOUR FELLOW
COLLEAGUES OUT OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON TO TAKE CARE OF OUR PEOPLE --
WE'RE DEALING WITH THESE HARSH.
CHOICES.
ARE FROM THE DROUGHT AND
EVERYTHING ELSE I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
CENTER HER TILE -- WHEN I THINK
SELF HELP ENTERPRISES FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE --
AND EVERYBODY IN THE VALLEY FOR
REALLY FALLEN TOGETHER -- I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A PRINCIPAL
CO AUTHOR ON THIS TO HELP MOVE
IT FORWARD IF THAT'S OKAY WITH
YOU.
ABSOLUTELY WHAT LEVEL
[inaudible]
GOOD MOVE [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
ALL RIGHT -- MADAM SECRETARY --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB FIVE
THIRTEEN ORDER THAT'LL THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
-ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I OUR QUE HAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN
[inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM GONNA TO G. WITH A
TO G. I AT SEVEN ZERO ZERO VERY
GOOD WELL GET A HOLD IT OPEN FOR
THE OTHER MEMBERS THANK YOU
MA'AM.
I BELIEVE.
WE ONLY HAVE ONE SENATOR HERE
THAT SENATOR LEYVA.
SO YEAH A AND YOU'VE WORKED VERY
HARD ON THIS BILL OF THE TITLE
IS COSMETIC FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR
INGREDIENTS RIGHT TO KNOW ACT OF
TWENTY NINETEEN THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS YOU
ARE WELCOME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF%
WE GREATLY.
APPRECIATE IT.
AND YOU KNOW THE BEST LAID PLANS
I WAS THE FIRST PERSON SIGNED IN
TO GO FIRST AND IT JUST DIDN'T
WORK OUT QUITE THAT WAY -- BUT
GLAD TO BE HERE.
I'M PLEASE THE FOLLOWING SEVERAL
MONTHS OF GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE BILL'S
SPONSORS AND INDUSTRY WE REACHED
A COMPROMISE AND THE LEAD
INDUSTRY ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
MOVED TO A NEUTRAL POSITION AS
YOU ALL KNOW SOMETIMES THAT IS
NO SMALL FEAT.
MEMBERS OF FIVE SEVEN FOUR IS A
BALANCED MEASURE THAT EMPOWERS
CONSUMERS PROVIDES APPROPRIATE
BUSINESS PROTECTIONS AND
ADVANCES PUBLIC HEALTH.
SPECIFICALLY SB FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR REQUIRES THE DISCLOSURE OF
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR INGREDIENTS
AND PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS THAT
APPEAR ON DESIGNATED AN
AUTHORITATIVE HAUSER CHEMICAL
LIST. TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THE P. H..
THIS BILL DOES NOT BAN ANY
PRODUCT IN GREEN ORREQUIRE
ADDITIONAL PRODUCT LABELING.
I JUST CAN'T WAIT.
I SAID OKAY.
SB FIVE SOME FOUR ALSO PROTECTS
TRADE SECRETS INCLUDING PRODUCT
INGREDIENT FORMULAS SO THAT WE
ARE PROTECTING VALUABLE RECIPES
AND FORMULATIONS.
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA TODAY THE
PUBLIC KNOWS MORE ABOUT THE
FRAGRANCE IGGY GRADIENTS AND
CLEANING PRODUCTS THAN THOSE
THAT WE USE TO CLEAN AND SENT
OUR BODIES PUT ANOTHER WAY WE
ACTUALLY KNOW MORE ABOUT THE
FRAGRANCES IN FLOOR CLEANERS.
DISINFECTANTS THAN WE DO IN
SHAMPOOS DEODORANTS AND BODY
SPRAYS WE ALSO KNOW VERY LITTLE
ABOUT THE FLAVORS IN CHAP STICKS
MOUTHWASH AND LIP GLOSSES AND I
FORGOT MY LITTLE STRAWBERRY FIZZ
LIP GLOSS THAT I USUALLY BRING
AND I LEFT IT ON MY DESK BUT I
WOULD LOVE TO KNOW.
WHAT MAKES STRAWBERRY PHYS
STRAWBERRY FEST?
CURRENTLY NO STATE OR FEDERAL
LAW REQUIRES A DISCLOSURE OF
FRAGRANCE OR FLAVOR INGREDIENTS
TO CONSUMERS OR REGULATORY
AGENCIES NOT EVEN THE FDA.
THIS LOOPHOLE ALLOWS CHEMICALS
TO HIDE UNDER THE WORD FRAGRANCE
OR FLAVOR ON THE LABELS OF
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS WITH LITTLE REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT.
OF THE SAFETY OF THOSE
INGREDIENTS YOU COULD SEE FOR
YOURSELF ON THE LABELS OF THE
PRODUCTS THAT YOU USE EVERY
MORNING AND NIGHT.
THOUSANDS OF CHEMICALS ARE USED
TO CREATE THE FRAGRANCES AND
FLAVORS THE COMPRISED THE BEAUTY
AND PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS WE
USE EVERY DAY.
SOME OF THESE CHEMICALS HAVE
BEEN LINKED TO NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS RANGING FROM ALLERGIC
REACTIONS TO REPRODUCTIVE HARM
AN INCREASED RISK OF BREAST
CANCER.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR ONE POWER
CONSUMERS TO MAKE EDUCATED
DECISIONS ABOUT WHICH PRODUCTS
TO USE WITH THEIR KIDS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
WITH THIS BILL WE ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT CONSUMERS AND
WORKERS HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
WHAT INGREDIENTS ARE IN THE
PRODUCTS THEY INTERACT WITH THAT
WORK AND BRING HOME TO THEIR
FAMILIES.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR ONE SURE
THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO BE
A NATIONAL AND GLOBAL LEADER ON
PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS BILL IS BROADLY SUPPORTED
BY LABOR PUBLIC HEALTH
ENVIRONMENTAL MULTI ETHNIC AND
CANCER PREVENT.
PREVENTION ORGANIZATIONS IS IT
ALL IT IS ALSO SUPPORTED BY
DOZENS OF BUSINESSES THAT ARE
FINDING MUCH SUCCESS IN
DISCLOSING FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR
INGREDIENTS INCLUDING.
PROCTER AND GAMBLE THE WORLD'S
LARGEST CONSUMER PRODUCTS
COMPANY AND UNILEVER THE SECOND
LARGEST BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COMPANY IN THE WORLD.
HERE WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS SUSAN
BLACK C. E. O. OF ECO PRODUCTS
IN JANET NEWMAN DIRECTOR PROGRAM
AND POLICY FOR BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS.
AND IS AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHTS YOU HAVE FOUR MINUTES
PLEASE SAID TRY TO IT TWO
MINUTES EACH SOUND ABOUT RIGHT
YES.
TAKE THE WHOLE FOR OKAY THAT'S
FINE DO THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON A DOCTOR QUIRK IN
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY YES TM
COMMITTEE.
I'M SUSAN GRIFFIN BLACK I'M THE
FOUNDER AND CO CEO OF E. --
PRODUCTS SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WITH A
STAFF OF TEN PEOPLE WE BEGAN
MAKING BOTANICALLY BASED BATH
AND BODY CARE PRODUCTS.
IN A SMALL SPACE IN THE BAY AREA.
TODAY WE ARE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
STRONG.
HAVE TWO BRANDS ONE IS EASY --
THE OTHER EVERYONE.
AND YOU CAN FIND OUR PRODUCTS IN
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND POINTS OF
DISTRIBUTION IN THE USA.
WE ARE MAKERS WE CARE VERY
DEEPLY ABOUT THE QUALITY AND
SAFETY OF OUR INGREDIENTS AND
HOW THEIR SOURCED.
WE CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF EACH OTHER.
AND OF OUR CUSTOMERS ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'VE HEARD MOST OVER THE
YEARS IS THAT WE HAVE THE BEST
SMELLING PRODUCTS IN THE MARKET
PLACE.
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF OUR
COMPANY WE PROVIDED FULL
GRADIENT DISCLOSURE ON FRAGRANCE
FLAVORS AND EVERY OTHER THING
THAT GOES INTO MAKING OUR
PRODUCTS.
WITHOUT A MARKETING DEPARTMENT
UNTIL ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO.
AND WITHOUT OUTSIDE FINANCING
INSTITUTIONAL FINANCING WE
SUCCESSFULLY BUILT A COMPANY
WHOSE REVENUE WAS FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND WE'VE
GROWN 20% YEAR OVER YEAR. ONE OF
THE REASONS FOR OUR SUCCESS IS
THAT WE'VE BEEN CUT WE'VE BECOME
AND WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN AN
ADVOCATE. FOR INGREDIENT
TRANSPARENCY TO GIVE OUR
CUSTOMERS THE ABILITY TO MAKE
HEALTHIER CHOICES FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
OUR CUSTOMERS TRUST US AND WE
VALUE EACH AND EVERYONE OF THEM.
I'M HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR AND AS SENATOR
LEAVE US SAID.
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR CHEMICALS
ARE USED IN THE MAJORITY OF
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS.
YET THESE INGREDIENTS ARE HIDDEN
FROM PUBLIC VIEW BECAUSE NO
FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES THE
DISCLOSURE OF ANY OF THESE
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR INGREDIENTS.
TO CONSUMERS MANUFACTURERS AND
EVEN REGULATORY AGENCIES.
THIS LABELING LOOPHOLE ALLOWS
CHEMICALS LINKED TO HARM AND
HUMAN IT TELL TO HARM HUMAN
HEALTH.
AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
HENCE THE CONVERSATION THAT.
CAME BEFORE THIS ONE IT'S ALL
VERY INTER DEPENDENT YOU KNOW
THESE CHEMICALS MAKE THEIR WAY
INTO OUR WATER SYSTEMS AND THEY
AFFECT EACH AND EVERYONE OF US
IN IN MANY WAYS.
ANYWAY THEY THEY ARE ABLE TO BE
HIDDEN UNDER THE WORD FRAGRANCE
OR FLAVOR WITHOUT REGULATORY IN
OVERSIGHT.
OF THE SAFETY OF THESE
INGREDIENTS.
IN ADDITION TO CHRONIC HEALTH
CONCERNS RESEARCH SHOWS THAT UP
212% OF THE GLOBAL POPULATION.
SUFFERS FROM FRAGRANCE ALLERGIES
TRANSLATING TO HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY THE LACK OF
INGREDIENT.
DISCLOSURE [inaudible]
FORTUNATELY.
THE SAFE AND CLEAN BEAUTY
COMPANIES LIKE OURS REPRESENT
THE FASTEST GROWING SEGMENT OF
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
MARKET.
ESTIMATED TO GENERATE OVER
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WHY IS THIS
TRUE.
BECAUSE PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW.
THIS IS NOT A TREND THIS IS
TRUST PEOPLE VOTE WITH THEIR
DOLLARS.
THIS RAPID GROWTH IS DUE IN PART
TO COMPANIES LIKE OURS WHO
RESPONDING TO INCREASING
CONSUMER DEMAND FOR INGREDIENT
TRANSPARENCY.
WE'RE SHOWING IT'S NOT ONLY
POSSIBLE BUT PROFITABLE FOR
COMPANIES TO BE TRANSPARENT.
MORE THAN THAT IT IS SIMPLY THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
IT IS A PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUE.
MANY OTHER COMPANIES KEEP THEIR
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR CHEMICALS
HIDDEN FROM PUBLIC VIEW.
QUITE SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY CAN.
AND IT'S NOT RIGHT AND IT'S NOT
FAIR THIS CREATES AN UNLEVEL
PLAYING FIELD.
WHERE SOME COMPANIES OFFER FULL
INGREDIENT TRANSPARENCY AND
OTHER COMPANIES ARE ALLOWED TO
KEEP IT?
A SECRET IT ALSO CREATES A BUYER
BEWARE SITUATION FOR CONSUMERS
AND WORKERS.
HE AND THE THIRTY FIVE SAFE
COSMETIC COMPANIES FROM
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BELIEVE
THAT EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT TO
KNOW WHAT HARMFUL INGREDIENTS.
EXCUSE ME COULD YOU -- JUST
YOU'RE.
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW WHAT IS IN
THEIR PRODUCTS THAT THEY USE
EVERY DAY.
IT.
IT IS NOT DIFFICULT TO DO THIS
WE'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS.
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT AND VERY
THANKFUL TO SENATOR LEYVA THANK
YOU THANK YOU -- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
TURN MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE IN SUPPORT.
MITCH DYER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
EMILY RASH WITH CAL PERK IN
SUPPORT.
HI LIANE TROUT NOT BEHALF OF
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS AND
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
PAUL YOU ARE SITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
SUSAN LITTLE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP IN
SUPPORT.
DEAL RICHTER ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THE SEVENTH FLEET FROM BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS ON
BEHALF OF THE OTHER. SEVENTY
EIGHT GROUPS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS IN ENVIRONMENT
HEALTH WOMEN LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND OTHER GROUPS WHO
COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT -- QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I MISSED MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AS SEVERAL A OF A
GRADE BELL I WILL BE SUPPORTING
IT.
I JUST WANT TO MENTION I HAVE
ANOTHER -- TOXIC CHEMICALS IN
COSMETICS BILL AND WOULD LOVE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HILL.
MOVED TO APPROVE.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE MOTIONS SECOND.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
MR OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER I JUST HAD A
QUESTION ABOUT LOGISTICS SO THE
BILL REQUIRES THAT A
MANUFACTURER WHOSE NAME APPEARS
ON A LABEL.
WOULD MAKE THESE DISCLOSURES IF
THEIR PRODUCTS ARE SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA SO IF YOU'RE A
MANUFACTURER OF WHAT WAS A FIZZY
CHAPSTICK -- MY STRAWBERRY FIFTH
STRAWBERRY FOR THIS OKAY IN IN
FLORIDA.
AND YOU SOLD A BUNCH TO A
DISTRIBUTOR WHO THEN DISTRIBUTED
IN CALIFORNIA HOW WOULD USE THE
MANUFACTURE KNOW.
THAT YOUR PRODUCTS ARE BEING
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA JUST WONDER
IF IT'S A REASONABLE
REQUIREMENTS YET THE
MANUFACTURER MAY NOT NOW BUT IF
YOU IF YOU WERE OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO IT'S SATAN SO MY STRAWBERRY --
PHYS IS MADE BY VICTORIA'S
SECRET SO IF THEY SELL THE
PRODUCT IN ONE STATE AND IT GETS
TAKEN CALIFORNIA WHICH WE KNOW
THEY ALREADY OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA IT WOULD BE INCUMBENT
UPON THE PERSON SELLING IT. TO
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE TO ADD THAT
TO THE LIST SO THE DISTRIBUTER
THE DISTRIBUTER SO BUT IT THE
THE BILL DOESN'T SAY THAT THE
BILL SAYS THE MANUFACTURERS
RESPONSIBLE.
AM I WRONG IN THAT THEY CAN GO
AHEAD I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT
THANK YOU JANET.
SO SO THIS BILL AMENDS THE SAFE
COSMETICS ACT WHICH CURRENTLY
REQUIRES COMPANIES SELLING.
COSMETICS WITH PROP SIXTY FIVE
CHEMICALS IN THEIR PRODUCTS --
TO CALIFORNIANS TO REPORT THE
PRESENCE OF THOSE CHEMICALS TO
THE SAFE COSMETICS PROGRAM.
AND AND THAT INCLUDES -- BUT WEB
BASED SALES SO SO THE COMPANY IN
FLORIDA SELLING SENATOR LEAVE US
CHAPSTICK.
IS REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE THE
FRAGRANCE INGREDIENTS IN THEIR
PRODUCTS IF THEY APPEAR ON THE
DESIGNATED LEST.
THE SAME AS A WEB BASED SELLER
IN ISRAEL OR ANYWHERE ELSE IN
THE WORLD SO THE CITY BECAUSE
MEDICS PROGRAM -- ACTUALLY
CONDUCTS OUTREACH TO THE
COSMETICS INDUSTRY THE FOURTEEN
THOUSAND COMPANIES THAT MAKE UP
THE COSMETICS INDUSTRY TO INFORM
THEM OF THEIR DUTY TO REPORT BUT
THERE REGULATORY DIVISIONS
WITHIN THOSE COMPANIES.
SHOULD BE IT -- DO THE DUE
DILIGENCE TO KNOW WHAT LAWS THE
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH IN THE
STATES WHERE THEY CONDUCT
COMMERCE.
OKAY THE I MEAN THAT MIGHT BE
TRUE FOR A LARGE COMPANY.
BUT I'M I'M THINKING OF A SMALL
MANUFACTURE THAT'S MAKING
SOMETHING YOUR LOCALLY -- LOCAL
PRODUCT IN FLORIDA OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT HI I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THEY STILL BECAUSE IF
YOU'VE GOT A WEB SALE TO AN
ADDRESS IN CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY
YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAVE SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IF YOU JUST SELL
A BUNCH OF THEM A THOUSAND OF
THEM TO A DISTRIBUTOR.
AND A DISTRIBUTOR GOES OFF AND
DOES WHATEVER THEY DO I'M NOT
SURE IT'S REASONABLE TO GO BACK
AND SAY TO THE MANUFACTURER YOU
HAVE BROKEN CALIFORNIA STATE LAW
BECAUSE WE'VE DISCOVERED. ONE OF
YOUR JERRY FIZZ CHOPSTICKS YOU
KNOW IN A STORE IN CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THE I DON'T
KNOW THAT WOULD HAPPEN I DON'T
KNOW WHO WOULD ENFORCE THAT WHO
WOULD FIND THAT AND SAY THEY
DIDN'T FIND THAT THE LIST FIND
THE INGREDIENTS ON THE LIST I
DON'T KNOW WHO THE ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY WOULD BE.
JUST TO ADD HERE -- FOR THE
AUDIENCE WHO MAY NOT BE FAMILIAR
WITH THE BILL WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT ADDING A LABEL ON THE
PRODUCT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HAVING IT LISTED.
AND SO IT CERTAINLY ANY THE
NATIONAL DISTRIBUTORS WILL
SIMPLY HAVE IT AND REGARDLESS
FOR EXAMPLE OF VICTORIA'S SECRET.
SELLS IT IN FLORIDA AND SOMEBODY
BUYS IT THERE AND CELLS IN
CALIFORNIA EVERYTHING'S TAKEN
CARE OF BECAUSE THEY ALREADY
HAVE THE DISCLOSURE ON THE
WEBSITE.
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING OF COURSE IS
A MUCH MORE SIMPLE THING LIKE
THERE'S AN INDEPENDENT
DISTRIBUTOR IN FLORIDA?
AND THEY DON'T KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE TO PUT IT ON THE WEBSITE
AND THEN IT GETS SENT OVER TO
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
TO THINK ABOUT -- AND THAT LET'S
THINK ABOUT IT -- I THINK YOU
HAVE YOU KNOW YOU'VE RAISED AN
ISSUE AND CERTAINLY FOR TO
MANUFACTURER WHO'S.
NOT NATIONAL AND SOMETHING STE
WE SHOULD HAVE WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT WE WANT TO
DO WITH THAT I THINK IT'S A
VALID QUESTION.
AND OUT.
SHE WILL DO THAT WILL DO THAT.
YEAH YOU'RE WELCOME IT'S
SOMETIMES I THINK WE DON'T
CONTEMPLATE EFFECT ON SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO MIGHT NOT HAVE A
FULL TIME GROUP PLANS OFFICER.
AND IF THAT'S EASY TO DO BECAUSE
YOU CAN JUST SET A THRESHOLD OF
BY GROSS ANNUAL SALES OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO EXAMPLES
PEOPLE.
ARE GETTING THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD.
AS USUAL YOU RAISE GOOD
QUESTIONS BY THE WAY I SHOULD
SAY MR OBERNOLTE IS NOT ONLY
RAISING GOOD QUESTIONS BUT HE'S
A SUBSTITUTE.
AND HE HE SEEMS TO KNOW AS MUCH
AS ANYONE WHO SERVES ON THIS
COMMITTEE INCLUDING ME AND I
JUST WANT TO COMPLIMENT YOU FOR
DOING YOUR HOMEWORK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- SHOW NO MORE
QUESTIONS I FORGOT TO ASK FOR
OPPOSITION.
I JUST TOOK THE WORD THAT THERE
WASN'T ANY.
BUT WE TRY TO BE TRUTHFUL AND HE
LEYVA YEAH.
ALL RIGHT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE WE
HAVE OPPOSITION DID WE JUST GET
A MOTION AND A SECOND YES SO.
LOOKS LIKE WE CAN CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB.
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR LEYVA DO YOU PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK HI QUIRK I
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT BOLD VOTING
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I POWER QUE HAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA HI HOLDEN
[inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MATHIS I WHAT A TO G. ACT RIGHT
TO CHECK HI. SIX VERY GOOD
[inaudible]
WE HAVE. SEVEN VOTES YOU'RE OUT
AND WILL ALLOW HOLD IT OPEN FOR
THE OTHER TWO MEMBERS VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS -- AGAIN -- I'M SORRY
SIX ABOUT.
THE BILL AND I'M SORRY WE NEED.
TO DO HERE.
OKAY OKAY SENATOR WIENER IT'S
GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE
[inaudible]
PERFECT TIMING.
THANK YOU.
FOR THERE ARE THIS IS A SB ONE
SIXTY SIX PROCESS WATER
TREATMENT SYSTEMS BREWERIES.
PLEASE PROCEED.
WILL THING MICHAEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF IT'S A
GERMAN THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL.
AND I'M HAPPY -- TO EXCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS TO TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE AN ANALYSIS -- SP ONE
SIXTY SIX WILL PROVIDE OUR
BREWERIES WITH THE OPTION.
NOT THE REQUIREMENT BUT THE
OPTION -- TO REUSE WATER ON SITE
FOR BOTH POTABLE AND NON POTABLE --
PURPOSES WHATEVER THEY CHOOSE --
ALTHOUGH THE DROUGHT -- IS
TEMPORARILY OVER WE KNOW THAT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT WILL NOT LAST
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LONG TERM.
STRUCTURAL WATER SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA WE BUILT A WATER
SYSTEM FOR A MUCH TINIER STATE --
IN OUR STATE OF FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE AND THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
WATER IN THE LONG RUN AND WE
NEED TO DO MORE -- TO BE
EFFICIENT -- AND WE ALSO NEED TO
CATCH UP.
ON WATER REUSE COUNTRIES LIKE
AUSTRALIA AND ISRAEL -- THAT --
HAVE A VERY VERY BAD -- PROBLEMS
OF WATER HAVE MADE MUCH BETTER
USE OF BUT HAVE DONE MUCH MORE
WATER USE WE IN CALIFORNIA ARE
BEHIND -- WE'RE GETTING BETTER
BUT WITH A LOT MORE WORK TO DO.
ALL RIGHT NOW -- IT TAKES ON
AVERAGE BETWEEN FIVE AND SEVEN
GALLONS OF WATER. TO PRODUCE ONE
GALLON OF BEER -- BUT WE COULD
RE USE THE SO CALLED PROCESS
WATER SUCH AS THE WATER USED FOR
CLEANING TANKS OR PACKAGING --
AND BY DOING THAT WE CAN CUT
THOSE FIGURES AND HALF IN TERMS
OF THE AMOUNT OF WATER PER
GALLON OF BEER.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NO UNIFORM HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS FOR ON SITE
ONSITE PROCESS WATER.
ARE RE USE SOMEONE EVER BREWERY
THE SIDE THERE ARE -- BREWERIES
THAT ARE WE USING WATER AND
THAT'S TERRIFIC INTO DOING THE
RIGHT THING.
THEY HAVE TO RECREATE THE WHEEL
IN TERMS OF THE PERMIT EVERY
TIME BECAUSE THERE IS NO
STANDARD APPROACH IN TERMS OF
GETTING THAT PROMISE.
BERMAN.
I SAID THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
THAT GUIDANCE AND MAKE IT MORE
EFFICIENT AND EASIER.
OFFER BREWERIES TO BE ABLE -- TO
IMPLEMENT THE SYSTEMS -- ONSITE
PROCESS WATER REFUSAL WILL
REMAIN COMPLETELY VOLUNTARY
UNDER THE BILL.
THE GOAL IS SIMPLY TO GIVE
BROUGH REEVES A BETTER TOOL --
TO IMPLEMENT WATER USE.
AS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME HERE TODAY.
IS UP PAULA KEY HOPE FROM THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
AND MELISSA AND WALKS IN ON
BEHALF OF ANHEUSER BUSCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PAULA KEY HOME THE DIRECTOR OF
WATER RESOURCES WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
OF SFPUC PC IS BEEN PROMOTING
WATER CONSERVATION FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
TODAY OUR RESIDENTIAL PER CAPITA
IS FORTY TWO GALLONS PER PERSON
PER DAY AMONG THE LOWEST IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER WE RECOGNIZE THERE'S
MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO USE WATER
EFFICIENTLY.
AND AS A SENATOR WIENER
MENTIONED THERE'S SIGNIFICANT
POTENTIAL -- TO SAVE WATER AND
USE WATER EFFICIENTLY IN
BREWERIES -- WE'VE HEARD FROM A
NUMBER OF BROUGH REASON OUR
COMMUNITY -- THAT ARE INTERESTED
IN CONSERVING WATER AND RE USING
PROCESS WATER ON SITE.
AND SO WE RECENTLY DEVELOPED OUR
OWN.
MCCOLLUM PATHOGEN CONTROL
STRATEGY -- TO ENCOURAGE --
BREWERIES TO TREAT IN RE USE
PROCESS WATER ON SITE -- AND OUR
OUR PATHOGEN OF ITS CONTROL
STRATEGY REALLY IS A STRAIGHT
FORWARD GUIDANCE -- TO HELP
BREWERIES REDUCE THEIR WATER
FOOTPRINT BUT IN CALIFORNIA TO
ENABLE OTHER BROUGH RESERVE
PROCESS OF WATER WE NEED
CONSISTENT STANDARDS FOR
INSTALLING WATER RECYCLING
SYSTEMS STATEWIDE.
AND SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY SIX
ACCOMPLISHES JUST THAT -- BY
REQUIRING OF THE STATE BOARD IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
ESTABLISH UNIFORM STANDARDS FOR
TREATING PROCESS WATER IN
BREWERIES -- WE COMMENDED
SENATOR WIENER FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT AND SPONSOR SB ONE SIX
SIX THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MULLIS
AMALEK SIN WITH ANHEUSER BUSCH I
STRAIGHT TO THE HEART OF THE
MATTER IN OUR VAN NUYS BREWERY
RIVER WE RECYCLE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION GALLONS OF WATER A DAY.
WE ONLY HAVE USE FOR TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THOSE GALLONS SO A
BILL LIKE THIS WILL HELP US WORK
WITH THE STATE TO FIND
ADDITIONAL CREATIVE WAYS TO USE
THAT WATER SO APPRECIATE YOUR
ABOUT.
FOR GREAT TESTIMONY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE IN SUPPORT
WE SUPPORT BENEFICIAL REUSE AND
RECYCLING OF WATER AND THINK
THIS IS THAT A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE THINKING.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
ARE YOU MISS ELECTION YOU CAN
SAID THERE'S PLENTY OF ROOM.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SEAN HIM WHEN I REPRESENT --
THE CALIFORNIA CRAPPER
DISSOCIATION.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO REGISTER
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN -- TO THE
COMMITTEE REGARDING SENATE BILL.
ONE SIXTY SIX OUR CONCERN CENTER
RUN THE IMPACT SB ONE SIXTY SIX
WILL HAVE ON THE NINE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY CRAFT VERSION STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AS WRITTEN SB ONE SIXTY SIX
APPEARS TO REQUIRE THE STATE'S
NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY CRAFT BREWS
TO REGISTER WITH C. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT.
A PUBLIC HEALTH AT A COST OF
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER YEAR
PER BREWERY.
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS STATES
THERE IS ALREADY CONFUSION OVER
THE NECESSITY OF CV PH
REQUIREMENTS.
WE REALLY REALLY WE FEEL VERY
STRONGLY THIS SEEMS TO BE
RESOLVED BEFORE THIS BILL MOVES
TO THE ASSEMBLY.
FOR ARM BEFORE IT'S CONSIDERED
BY THE ENTIRE LEGISLATURE -- WE
ALSO INTRODUCED AB SEVEN FORTY
SIX EARLIER THIS YEAR EXCUSE ME
WE SPONSORED WAS INTRODUCED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM WOOD A TO
ADDRESS THIS CONFUSION BY
EXEMPTING BREWERIES FROM HAVING
TO REGISTER.
AS FOOD PROCESSORS ON THIS WOULD
BRING BREEZE IN PARITY WITH
WINERIES IN CALIFORNIA THEY ARE
EXIT CURRENTLY EXEMPTED FROM
FROM THIS REQUIREMENT.
THIS REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS
IN THIS FEE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
SO WE WERE SEEKING TO FIX THIS
PROBLEM -- AND WE RAN INTO A
SITUATION WHERE THERE IS A
CONFLICTING MEASURE ON FOR THAT
KIND OF WAS GOING.
TO PUSH IT OUT A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER -- SO WE JUST.
FEEL LIKE WE NEED A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME TO REMOVE THESE THE CV
PH REQUIREMENT ON CRAFT
BREWERIES [inaudible]
WORD.
STRONGLY STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES BEING THE ONE THE
DRESSES REGULATIONS AND FORCES
REGULATION SO.
WAS MY COMMENTS TODAY AND REALLY
REALLY REALLY ONE OF WITH THIS
COMPANY DOLLAR FEE.
FOR THAT'S LAVAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER WINNER -- FOR SO WE
HAVEN'T RECEIVED A LETTER FROM
YOU.
NOW WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED A LETTER
WOULD YOU MIND AS SUBMITTING ONE
SO THAT THE DOCTOR CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT YOUR CONCERN CERTAINLY
AND WE WERE AWARE OF THAT WE
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT GETTING HAVING
THE TIME TO GET THAT LETTER ANTI.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT OUR OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
NO OTHERS IN OPPOSITION -- LET'S
SEE THEN WE WOULD ASK FOR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE THANK YOU A SENATOR WIENER
APPRECIATE.
THE WORK YOU'RE DOING -- IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN I TRIED TO WORK
ON THE IDEA OF FREE CYCLE WATER
FOR BEER AFTER A TRIP TO US
REALLY A I I IT DIDN'T GO
ANYWHERE BUT I'M HAPPY THAT THE
DISCUSSION IS BACK IN IN A
DIFFERENT FORM -- AND WE'RE
HAVING THAT DISCUSSION -- AND SO
I WILL BE SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
BILL EXCITED I WAS EXCITED TO
SEE THIS WHEN I GOT A BRIEF THIS
THIS MORNING BY MY STAFF I WOULD
LIKE TO BE ADDED ON AS A CO
AUTHOR.
BUT I DO HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT --
THE OPPOSITION AND WHILE WE
DON'T HAVE A LETTER HAVE YOU HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK INTO THIS
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR FEE ISSUE AT
ALL.
YET SO ON I THANK YOU AND WE
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU AS A CO
AUTHOR -- I WAS AWARE OF YOUR
WORK WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
ON THE FORGET THE SPECIFIC ISSUE
I JUST WANT TO SPEAK GENERALLY
WE HAVE BEEN ATTEMPTING TO WORK
WITH THE CRAFT BREWERS THE
ENTIRE YEAR -- MY STAFF HAS PUT
ON ENDING TIME AND ENERGY INTO
TRYING TO WORK WITH THE CRAFT
BREWERS.
AND IT IS CHAT WE JUST KEEP
HITTING WALLS YOU'LL NOTICE THAT --
ANCHOR -- BREWERY IS A IS A
SUPPORTER OF THE BILL WE HAVE --
I'VE SPOKEN WITH INDIVIDUAL
CRAFT BREWERS WHO ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE BUT THE ASSOCIATION
HAS ON OFFICE BE BLUNT BEEN
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO WORK WITH
ME MADE CHANGES TO THE BILL WE
TOLD WE EVEN REDUCE THE BILL TO
A SPOT BILL. TO GET OUT OF THE
SENATE AS A SIGN OF GOOD FAITH
TO SAY WE WERE REDUCE IT -- TO A
SPOT BILL WORK WITH YOU IN THE
RE EXPANDED OUT AND WE WERE JUST
UNABLE -- TO REALLY EFFECTIVELY
WORK WITH THE ASSOCIATION I HOPE
THAT THAT CHANGES I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THEM ON THIS.
ON THIS BILL WILL WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE MEMBERS OF THE
INDUSTRY LIKE ANHEUSER BUSCH
LIKE ANCHOR WHO'VE BEEN ARE
WILLING TO WORK WITH US.
THIS BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE
REGISTRATION THE BILL APPLIES TO
BREWERIES THAT ARE REGISTERED
THIS BILL DOES NOT MANDATE THAT
ANYONE REGISTER WITH CD PH.
I'M AWARE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOODS BILL -- WHICH I SUPPORT --
SO THAT THEY ARE NO LONGER
CONSIDERED FOOD PROCESSORS --
AND AS THAT WE INDICATE THE
CROPPERS EARLIER THIS WEEK WERE
HAPPY TO WORK TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT I DON'T WANT THIS BILL
TO IN ANY WAY COMPLEX WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOODS.
BILL SO WE'RE COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE TO HARMONIZE A
BECAUSE I AM SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT
HE'S DOING.
CONTROL PLAYERS WILL COME TO THE
TABLE.
TO FIND A SOLUTION BEFORE IT
DOES HIT THE FLOOR I UNDERSTAND
A CRAFT.
BREWER HAS VERY DIFFERENT
CONSTRAINTS THAT UNANSWERED BUSH
OR EVEN AN ANCHOR THAT IS
SOMEWHERE IN THE MIDDLE.
OF THAT AND SO TWELVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A IS A PRETTY SIZEABLE
DOLLAR AMOUNTS AND SO I DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS --
IN THE NEAR FUTURE TO FIND A
SUITABLE SOLUTION FOR EVERYBODY.
CERTAINLY AND AND MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS -- ACTUALLY HAVE THE
SYSTEMS IN OPERATION.
SIERRA NEVADA BRING COMPANY
BEING PROBABLY ONE OF THE
LARGEST -- OUR ON SITE.
TREATMENT SYSTEMS RUSSIAN RIVER
BRING COMPANY THEY JUST BUILT
THEIR BEAUTIFUL GIANT NEW VERY
IN WINDSOR CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE
ONE OF THE SYSTEMS BUT AND BY
COMPANY NAME CAME RENOVATION.
REPUBLIC BRING COMPANY SEISMIC
BRING COMPANY STONE BRING OF ANY
WE HAVE MANY MEMBERS I CAN DO
THIS.
MOST OF THEM ARE WELL
ESTABLISHED BUSINESS SO WHEN WE
SEE THE TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
FEE THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WHICH IS.
OF CONCERN IN THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS WE JUST REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE TIME TO
CLEAR THAT UP TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT ISN'T THE CASE.
THESE THINGS ARE HARD TO PUT
BACK IN THE BOTTLE NO PUN
INTENDED.
ONCE THEY THEY GET A MOVE PASSED
THE FOUR OF THE PERCEIVED
GOVERNMENT SIGNATURE.
ON AND AND WE REALLY DO HOPE TO
WORK ON THIS BILL WITH THE
AUTHOR YEAH.
AND DAT JUST IT IS THE AND THEN
MY COMMITTEE -- STAFF WILL MAKE
SURE I'M CORRECT ABOUT THIS.
NO ONE WHO IS ACCUSED ME IF A
BREWERIES NOT RECYCLING WATER
THEY CERTAINLY DO NOT HAVE TO
PAY THE TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
FEE.
IT'S ONLY THOSE THAT ARE DOING
THE RECYCLING THAT PERHAPS UNDER
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE TO AND
YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE --
SENATOR THAT THAT'S THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO PAY THAT IS THAT
CORRECT UNDER EXISTING LAW WE
WITH THIS BILL DOES NOT MANDATE
THAT THEY REGISTER OR PAY THE
FEE -- THEY THEY WERE AND WHAT
BUT WHATEVER NEEDS TO BE WORKED
OUT AROUND CD PH BECAUSE LIKE I
SAID I DO SUPPORT.
A SUMMER WHAT'S BILL TO TRY TO
GET CITY PH.
OUT OF THAT IN TERMS OF
CLASSIFICATIONS FOOD PROCESSORS --
AND SO WE WILL WORK WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ATTEMPT TO WORK WITH
THE ASSOCIATION. TO RESOLVE --
THIS AND ANY OTHER ISSUE THAT WE
CAN RESULT CURRENT SO THEN TO
SUMMARIZE IF ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WOODS BILL IS PASSED.
AND REACHES THE ARE GOVERNOR'S
DESK AND OUR IS SIGNED.
THEN IT WOULD BE VERY CLEAR THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO PAY THE
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PERIOD
WHETHER THEY RECYCLE WATER OR
NOT.
IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR
STAFF IS.
MAKING UP AHEAD GESTURE.
THE PERHAPS STAFF YOU COULD SAY
SOMETHING DIRECTLY.
IT SURE SHOULD AB SEVENTY FORTY
SEVEN FORTY SIX PASS.
AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
WE ARE PROCESSING WOULD BE
EXEMPT FROM THE SHERMAN FOR DRUG
COSMETIC ACT THEREBY ELIMINATING.
YOUR PROCESSING FROM CBS'S
PURVIEW SO THIS IS YOUR BILL
SENATOR WIENER WOULD REQUIRE.
ONLY MAKE THOSE BREWERIES THAT
ARE LICENSED BY C. PH ELIGIBLE
TO USE THE WATER RECYCLING.
AS THE BILL AS DRAFTED SO I
THINK I THINK THAT CAN BE
RECONCILED.
AM I JUST AMENDMENTS NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT BETWEEN THE TWO BILLS
YES AND WE ARE AND BECAUSE OUR
BILL WAS DRAFTED BASED ON THE
CURRENT LAW -- OBVIOUSLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT'S BILL IS
MOVING ALONG PARALLEL TO OURS --
BUT WE WERE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT OURS IS HARMONIZED WITH
WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD IS
DOING SO I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
ANY DISAGREEMENT WITH THE
ASSOCIATION ON ALL RIGHT SO I
HAVE A QUESTION WHICH IS.
IF YOU'RE GONNA USE RECYCLE
WATER AND GET EVERYTHING DONE
THE WAY IT'S JUST SAD.
THEN WITH A COMPANY USING
RECYCLED WATER HAVE TO PAY A
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLAR ANNUAL FEE.
WITH THE WORDS BILL NOW.
WHICH BILL NO SELF THAT PASSES.
THEN IT IS VERY CLEAR THEY WILL
NOT BE A FEE.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING.
AND IS THAT YOUR UNDERSTANDING
AS WELL MY TECHNICAL EXPERTS
RIGHT CENTER WINTERS BILL WOULD
NOT IMPOSE A FEED IT WOULD NOT
REQUIRE LICENSE JR.
BUT THE BILL WOULD JUST NEED TO
BE CORRECTED TO CLARIFY THAT THE
AN ELIGIBLE BREWERY COULD USE
THE ONSITE PROCESS WATER.
WITHOUT HAVING TO BE LICENSED SO
JUST CLARIFYING THE PURVIEW OF
THE TWO STATE AND AND WE INTEND
TO DO THAT.
ALL RIGHT SELL IT IS CLEAR THE
AMENDMENT THAT HAS TO BE TAKEN.
ARM AND WE HAVE TO MAKE.
SO I WILL GIVE YOU THE OPTION OF
PERHAPS DOUBLE JOIN YOUR BILL
WITH MR WORDS BECAUSE THEN IT
WOULD BE VERY CLEAR THAT THEY
BOTH HAVE TO PASS.
AND TOGETHER WITH AN AMENDMENT
IT WOULD BE VERY CLEAR THAT THEY
WON'T HAVE TO PAY THAT FEE I
KNOW THAT'S A BIG ASK BUT THAT'S
A POSSIBILITY.
I WOULD PREFER NOT.
TO PLACE A LINK THE TWO BUT I'M
REPRESENTING TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HARMONIZE
OUR BILL WITH MR ALRIGHT LET YOU
WILL FIND A WAY.
WE WILL OUT ALL RIGHT THAT'S
ONLY ONE OPTION THERE COULD BE
ETHICS ALL RIGHT.
ARM AND I WILL.
TELL THE COMMITTEE THAT WE WILL
FOLLOW THE BILL AND WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT HAPPENS WE WILL USE OUR
EXPERTISE.
AND MAKE SURE THAT YOUR CONCERNS
ARE MATT -- THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- THEN THE SL MEMBER
GARCIA DID YOU HAVE AN ISSUE
QUESTION.
ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE.
I MUST SAY WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
DOING GREAT ON THE QUESTIONS
THIS DAY [inaudible]
SO.
YOU KNOW I HAVE A REPUTATION FOR
ASKING HARD QUESTIONS IT SEEMS
TO BE PASSED ON TO THE REST OF
THE COMMITTEE.
ANYWAY -- SO I THINK WE'RE DONE --
PERHAPS YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
SENATOR RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ALL RIGHT.
THE REQUEST FOR AN AYE VOTE THE
MOTION.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE REPEAT
THE MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TWO SB ONE
SIXTY SIX SENATOR WINNER.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND WE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I POWER CAN.
THERE CAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS HI MURATSUCHI. SIX OF SIX
MONTHS NOW WITHOUT.
I AM CALLING.
I HAVE ONE ONE YOU KNOW AND SO
MR FOLDER. FIFTEEN MINUTES OF
CHEESE.
LAST BILL.
OUR AND IF MR HOLDING WE GET
HERE IN THE NEXT TEN MINUTES OR
SO -- WE CAN FINISH IT FINISH UP
THE HEARING TODAY.
YOU SEEM TO HAVE A LOT OF
SUPPORT HERE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
I'LL JUST BE VERY BRIEF -- THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD IT WILL BE ACCESSING FUNDS
FOR REPLACEMENT DISTRICT TO
ALLOW ARE IMPORTANT HOME WATER
CLEAN UPS AND OUR DISTRICT --
ESPECIALLY THOSE REPLACEMENT
DISTRICT IT SAVES MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND MILLIONS OF GALLONS
OF WATER AND ARE.
AND PROTECT OUR ENVIRONMENT SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE VOTE
WITH ME TODAY IS MISTER REED
BEEN HOW HIS TESTIMONY ONLY BE
ABOUT FORTY FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU
I HEARD FORTY FIVE SECONDS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BABRI
WITH READ GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
ON BEHALF OF THE WATER
REPLACEMENT DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
PLEASED TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
MY ALL RIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY YOU KNOW WHAT TO
DO NEXT.
SO I WAIT WE HAVE -- I'M SORRY
SUPPORT NOW POSITION I'M SORRY.
ALL RIGHT SUPPORT ASKING US ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AND
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
NOW WE CAN GO.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SIX SB FIVE
NINETEEN SENATOR BRADFORD THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I OUR QUE HAN.
BAUER-KAHAN HI CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA HOLDEN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS HI WHAT A TO G..
THAT'S BY BOATS.
THAT'S FIVE VOTE YOU OUT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PROJECT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT -- WHILE WE'RE HERE
CAN WE GO OVER ANY BILLS THAT --
I TH BELIEVE MR GARCIA ARAMBULA
VOTED ON ALL THE BILLS.
SO ANYTHING THAT -- ADD ONS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR
.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH CONSISTS ON OF ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB SIX THIRTY THREE STERN.
I ITEM NUMBER NINE SB SIX NINETY
WESSEL ITEM NUMBER TEN SB SEVEN
TWENTY SIX AT ALL.
THE VOTE STANDS NOW IT'S SEVEN
ZERO OBERNOLTE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I OKAY.
EIGHT ZERO ALL RIGHT.
GOD NEXT BILL.
I'VE BEEN
[inaudible] TO FOR
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ON EVERY
.
THAT WAS BACK.
IN THE ROLE RIGHT AND MARK.
OKAY -- WERE OPENING THE ROLE
FOR ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS AS
BEFORE FOURTEEN COVER A AT ALL.
THE VOTE STANDS AT THREE ONE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I OUR QUE
HAN.
OUR QUE HANNAH I HOLDEN
[inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MATHIS NOW.
SO THAT BRINGS THE VOTE TO FOR
CHIU THERE.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE SB FIVE THIRTEEN O'DONNELL
THE VOTE STANDS AT SEVEN ZERO
OUR QUE HAN.
OKAY AND I HOLDEN.
THE VOCALS.
TO EIGHT ZERO THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB FIVE NINETEEN
BRADFORD.
THE VOTE STANDS AT FIVE ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I HOLDEN.
WHAT A TO G.?
SO THE VOCALS.
TO SIX ZERO THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR LEYVA.
THE VOTE STANDS AT SIX ZERO
BAUER-KAHAN.
OUR CAN I HOLDEN.
FOCUS.
TO SEVEN ZERO USUALLY HERE NO
SIR OKAY.
I THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
I LOVE IT.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR IT
STANDS AT EIGHT ZERO OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE.
NINE ZERO THANK YOU AGAIN MR
OBERNOLTE FOR STANDING IN TODAY.
OKAY SO WHEN WE COME AND GO BACK
TO START.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO START
FROM THE BEGINNING AGAIN.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TWO SP ONE
SIXTY SIX WIENER THE VOTE STANDS
AT SIX ZERO MELENDEZ.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I WOULD A TO G..
AT SEVEN ZERO ALL RIGHT AND BILL
IS OUT [inaudible]
AGAIN [inaudible]
OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AS BEFORE
FOURTEEN CABALLERO THE VOTE
STANDS AT FOUR TWO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE THAT BRINGS THAT TO
FIGHT [inaudible]
TO FORGET.
THE BILL IS OUT THEN.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB FIVE
THIRTEEN OH DOUBLE THE VOTE
STANDS AT EIGHT ZERO HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I TAKES A TWO NINE ZERO I
REMEMBER SIX SB FIVE NINETEEN
BRADFORD VOTE SENSE STANDS AT
SIX ZERO MELENDEZ.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I SEVEN ZERO THREE
MOORLACH TWO G..
I DON'T NUMBER SEVEN SB FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR LEYVA.
OF THE VOTES AT SEVEN ZERO
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
EIGHT ZERO ALL RIGHT SO ARE WE
HAVE MISTER MERRETT SU CHI IS.
I NEED TO ADD ON FOR ONE BILL MY
CORRECT ON THAT.
AND THIS MELENDEZ.
ALL RIGHT SO MISS MELENDEZ DOES
NOT WANT TO ADD ON AT THIS TIME.
SO WE JUST HAVE MISTER
MURATSUCHI I ON ONE BILL WHICH
WILL IS THAT.
SB ONE SIXTY SIX WIENER.
SB ONE SIXTY SIX WIENER WHICH IS
ALREADY PASSED.
ARM LET'S TRY AND GET A HOLD OF
MISTER MURATSUCHI AND SEE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD ON I'LL WAIT
FOR TEN MINUTES TILL FIVE
MINUTES OF FOR ALSO.
THE FIVE NINETEEN RECORD AS WELL
SO THERE TWO BILLS AND ALSO --
FIVE NINETEEN BRADFORD AND CLEAN
WATER AND RECYCLED WATER FOR
BERRIES -- IF WE CAN HAVE THE
SERGEANTS CALL MR MERRY SU CHI'S
OFFICE AND SEE IF HE WOULD LIKE
TO COME IN AT ON OKAY HE'S ON
THE WAY VERY GOOD THANK YOU
[inaudible]
UP.
SO MISS MELENDEZ AND THE HEAD.
AND MISTER MURATSUCHI I DO NOT
WISH TO CONTINUE TO ADD ON SO WE
WILL CALL THE HEARING AID MAN
THANK YOU